Hello everybody!
Hello, welcome.
And hello.
Hello.
Hello Mickey.
Howdy.
Howdy, howdy, howdy.
Hold on.
I'm taking a sipy.
My throat is a little...
A little icky today.
A little icky.
I keep like...
And coughing and stuff.
So, I don't know.
Hopefully.
Sound...
Okay.
I don't think I'm getting sick.
Yeah, I have been drinking water.
I have been.
Yeah, just a lot of like...
Oh!
No.
Um, but...
It better not be sick!
I have too much to do!
Also, delayed, this would be the most delayed con sickness,
no?
A whole week later?
That'd be crazy!
Whoa.
Let me get a...
Let me get a throats and something.
something.
What's it called?
Lazenja!
Lazen... Lazenz...
Hello, Minto and Ivo's like you!
Hope you've had a nice Sunday so far.
Happy to chill with Minto on this wonderful evening.
Happy Sunday!
Thank you, Kamo!
Minto, can you sing that one catchy song that's trending
from Kodoja?
Things you can't fix?
it reminds me wait okay though kodo-chan was like one of my
favorite anime ever when i was a little baby ghost i loved
that show so much and the fact that it's like trending now
i'm like yes more people should know kodo-chan because it's
such a good show it's so good yeah i know exactly what
you're talking about though i think about that i think about
that oh my god Thank you guys for the Super Chats!
The lettuce is two weeks, but that's a whole different kind
of ick.
I'm getting the ick from lettuce.
I'm getting...
It gives me the ick.
Make sure the Super Chats bank.
Maybe a long incubation period.
Lettuce is even longer incubation.
Why is everybody talking about the lettuce?
I think I would know.
If this...
I don't think my throat would be affected by the lettuce.
I saw this trailer before Spider-Man for a movie called The
End of a...
Oak Street.
Oh, that's the one with the dinosaurs, right?
Right, Mari?
Yeah, I think.
Right?
Hi, Minto, how are you?
I hope you're doing wonderfully.
Hello, Brendan.
You too.
I'm doing good.
Thank you.
Ooh.
I wish I could make Mint, my pal.
You want me to do your bidding and your farming and your
mining, huh?
Is it because I like Minecraft?
You're like, oh, Minto would love to mine and farm and beat
up other creatures.
Hold on, I said I was gonna get a throat.
Hold on, I
got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
The power of salad.
It's strong.
Yeah, I'm right.
Let us move on from this topic.
I think we talk about lettuce, the poop lettuce, literally
every stream now.
We might be obsessed, you guys.
I didn't even bring it up first, though.
You guys did.
We might be obsessed.
Are we rabid?
It's the new cannibalism.
No, please, no.
Surject, welcome back.
And Kotei, welcome back.
And that one, that guy, welcome back.
I blame you for me and Binging Pal world like crazy.
Okay, but it's like so good.
There's so much you can do in Palworld.
I feel empowered.
You get it?
Like, empowered, but in Palworld.
Crack myself up.
It's better than Pete, or is it IDK?
Spanks, don't stop.
Stop, you're summoning them.
ViviCore, thank you so much for the five.
Get there!
Master Paladin, happy!
birthday happy birthday happy happy birthday two years of
vicky ph thank you my new favorite way to play pow world is
with ninto in the background also playing pow world let's
play pow world together
i am i am be abu baby well i'm proud two months military
thank you thank you so much for too much.
Thank you, baby, baby.
Hardest boy.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Is the cannibalism timer if we bring it up first?
No.
I'm gonna bring it up.
Or...
Yeah.
I have to bring it up.
How the world is such a fun game to watch, honestly.
I'm glad you guys are enjoying it because I'm really
enjoying playing it.
So, fun fact, lettuce is actually French for the tus.
The tush?
Is it a prophecy?
Let us being tush?
And then...
That's where Pooh comes from.
Shall we play Power World?
I was in the middle of making a sword.
And I will do that today.
La push?
Thank you, Dr. Minto.
Of course.
So I will be on the sloppy server again.
I think Matara is playing.
If we play with her, we play with her.
If not, that's fine.
Yeah, my egg!
My egg!
I'm so excited.
I wonder if she's here.
Matara?
Oh.
Hello.
Hello?
Thank you, she said.
Nice horse.
She's ignoring me?
No, wait!
Who is this?
Where's my egg?
No!
My egg.
If no one can have it.
Or if I can't have it.
No one can have it.
Hello?
Oh, shit!
Hi!
Did I call you on Discord?
No.
Wait, I'm playing again.
Oh, shit.
Ah, you caught me.
Hi!
Oh my god, look, look, look, look, min, min, min, min!
Look, I found him in an egg.
He's all mine.
And I can ride him.
You knew!
That's mine!
What?
Look!
Oh, good is on fire.
He's on fire!
Look, I'm so fast.
Look, look, look.
You named him, I hatched him?
Yes, look, look, look.
I can go the distance.
Isn't this fun?
I'm leaving.
Do you want to kill the Chillit together?
Oh, you can't do it by yourself.
I killed it by myself last time.
Oh, I was okay.
I was going to wait for you, but okay, no problem.
No, let's kill him.
I'm just saying you're strong enough.
That's all I'm saying.
I am.
I was going to say, for real though, I'm going to go and
find you some like wolves or something to make it like i
actually want to find them for the girls and you i guess for
what so that we can be fast and furious i am fast look at my
chillit wait you can ride the chillit yeah i'm oh bye let's
go get a chillit wait wait wait wait wait can we actually
race oh no my guy's really slow on land unless you want to
race in the water Look at my man.
Which one?
He was bathing when I came in.
He is bathing right now.
Man, you can't do this.
They have to fall in love slowly.
He's scaring him off.
You're scaring him.
No, he's in love, I promise.
I thought you like girls.
I like girls and I also like my man that does my bidding.
He has been really helpful, by the way.
He was fixing my stuff.
He was making the little balls.
He was doing all of it.
Yeah, he's awesome.
He trained him good.
Thank you.
I feel like I did too.
I got to get my deer that I can ride, actually.
What's this, by the way?
I was watching clips today of you.
Basically, the Wisps were telling me that, sorry, the Wisps
were telling me that they're going to walk around with their
arms outstretched at every convention, hoping you'll just
kind of stumble into those.
Next time you watch my clips on stream, I need royalties.
I thought we discussed this every time you show my face you
just send me money okay the check will be in the mail yes
mistress are you making a bow or something I am why you want
it no it just finished your little guy was helping me make
the bow I can make a gun oh this is a grappling gun wait I
want the grappling gun is actually such a perfect trope yeah
yeah wait is it a big gun?
I wonder.
I don't know.
Everything's a big gun to you.
Yeah, everybody's going to be T-posing at conventions.
Yeah, I'm right.
I told them, too, you know, I told them what I smell like.
I told them long pink wig, hagg's hat, maybe a Matara con
t-shirt, you know.
You're going to walk right into them.
Oh, yeah.
Honestly, that might be the setup.
Yeah.
But you heard part of why, how I identified you, right?
Yeah, the boobies.
That's what I told them, too.
Yeah, so they need that.
That's like the most They need soft breast.
Soft unbroad breast.
You're like, Matara, I'm live, please.
So are you.
Well, they're used to me talking about soft unbroad breast.
Oh.
Are they used to you talking about soft unbroad breast?
What's an unbroad?
Like, without the bra.
Unbroad.
I just have an accent.
Racist.
oh no guys the audio for matura is cutting out i think i
think the game is uh oh no i don't know what's going on now
how do i make the gun is it over here or do i need the
weapons i think i need the weapons thing don't i okay hold
on beautiful hold on i want to see how far i can walk away
before she hears me stinky i can hear you i can hear you
barely hear you.
Can you hear me now?
Okay, you can hear me like now.
I can hear her still.
Okay, hold on.
What was I making?
I could like barely hear her.
Okay, I made the grappling gun.
My sword.
Yes.
I need the ingots.
okay let's make let's get some ingots real quick oh perfect
i hope i hope were those combined let's see ingots wait oh
sword i think i might need her help though no i should not
be thank you so much for the gifted never heard her so quiet
before i think the gun it doesn't the schematic doesn't show
up i keep seeing this lock picking it tool and I keep
thinking that it is a like a barber set you know like with
the how they shave the beards I'm gonna try the sword where
she takes it from me though yeah we got to get the weapons
bench where'd she go anyway hmm I don't No, it really took a
long time before.
Yeah, I don't have a better workbench yet.
I have to unlock it still.
I don't have it unlocked yet.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
She's over there.
No, what is she doing?
Do you think she and I could take on the big beast?
I can't believe she hatched my egg, except I totally can
believe it.
You know how long I waited for that dang egg?
Yes, there is fall damage.
Yes, what's the new build of new stuff?
Oh, pal.
Essence condenser.
Increasing a pal's rank.
Dude.
Hoit.
How long has she been playing?
And how much you want to bet?
She hasn't.
she hasn't done anything for the base
maybe we go do the uh the quest the tutorial
where is it though it seems quite far yeah it seems quite
far
quest time hi what are you doing what are you doing Oh.
Leaving, I guess.
Ouch.
Okay.
Okay, fine.
Sure.
Let's go to the hypocrite hill.
Yeah, she ditching me.
There will be another tower on the way.
I don't know why the marker's all the way there.
I have no idea.
Wait.
Come on.
I'm headed this way.
Let's go.
Ah!
Oh, that was close.
Oh, is that a...
That is.
I'm just gonna drop.
I'm trusting.
Yes.
Don't try for the muffly.
It's not worth your life.
She's intimidated by my grappling gun.
Many are saying this.
Quite honestly.
Let's go try...
Let's try going around.
Oh good.
Oh.
Not enough stamina.
What is this?
Depresso.
Poor guy.
Wanna be depresso.
Get me off.
There we go.
I can't see...
Wait.
Boop the snoot.
I want to see him, though.
Whoa, hold up.
I'm not a pal, okay?
Don't go pulling out a pal sphere on me.
So what do you think of this costume?
Spot on Depressor, right?
Haha.
I absolutely love...
I absolutely adored Depressor.
Next thing I knew, I'd gone and made a whole costume.
Haha.
You know what would be fun if I made you one as well.
problem is I'm out of supplies.
Bring me the materials and whip yours up.
Wait, I want!
I want one!
Bring 20 high quality cloth and 100 venom glands.
Go and become depressive.
Oh my, wait.
I don't know if I want this actually.
But I think of, maybe I'm good.
Wait.
I might be okay.
I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm actually.
Well, there we go.
We're fine.
No, don't.
Come back.
You could catch him.
I could catch him.
It's like, are you sure you're not a depresso?
Yoink.
Where was that?
What is this little guy?
A floppy.
Sounds like my career.
Am I right?
VADANF.
Yay!
Okay.
We...
How many...
How spheres do I have?
33!
Alright, let's try and catch some...
Oh, this guy's kind of tough, though, for me.
What level am I?
Er...
13?
16?
Yeah.
What are you?
30!
Wait, everybody's so expensive here.
You think I could do this cave?
Level 29, boss, guys.
Maybe...
If Matara and I did it together...
I don't know.
Everybody is expensive here!
Ah!
Wait, how'd that happen?
Oh shoot.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Oh no no no no no no, no, no, no, no, no!
Don't touch him!
Don't touch him.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch!
Ouch!
Oh nice.
Wait, who's...
Is that someone new?
Floppy.
Go back to Floppy.
Holy cow.
Okay, we can do this.
We can do this, guys.
Ouch!
Get off?
Get me off of here?
Um...
Uh...
Ouch!
Yeah, yeah, keep going.
We'll try.
Uh, dear?
Come back.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, you.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think...
Oh, no!
No!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my god.
It's a mess.
Wait.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
I'm so I'm so dead.
It's it's over for us everybody.
It's over for us.
What the heck is that?
Oh, it's a it's a bomb
Come on, let's go we're getting out of here
We're getting out of here
We're fine I was so close to catching that bunny though kind
of mad I was so close to catching the bunny.
I'm a little mad
No bow.
I was a little frightened and forgot how to play the game.
I still feel like I could have done it.
Are you okay?
Oh yeah, he's...
Oh dear, he's coming back.
What was it for?
No, it was for...
Defensive, yeah, okay.
Valid, thank you.
Yeah, we're in a bit of a high level area, which is kind of
crazy.
I guess they expect you to be higher level at this point.
We'll go back.
Are we for real right now?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Just fast travel.
Get the hell out of here!
All I did was run into it!
There's some- Oh, there's Mint's little guy.
Hi!
Box!
Oh.
Sorry.
What happened?
I stubbed my toe.
No, I stubbed my toe.
Oh.
Do you want to help me make something?
Hi.
Oh, hi, Lyme.
Oh, I guess.
Yeah, I will.
Oh.
What do you want?
I want to make a sword, but it will take a really long time.
Yep, I'll help you.
Okay.
And in the meantime, we can play 21 questions!
Okay, help me make it.
Help me make it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So, Mint, when was the last time you cried?
Um, I think today.
Happy cry?
Okay.
uh overwhelmed drive are you making oh no um yeah no it's
just a lot five minutes ago five minutes ago i i almost died
to a floppy a floppy yeah what my career but um okay okay
miss top of the world i know it's stressful but you got this
oh yeah oh yeah what are you working on On the server or in
general in like my life?
Tell me all about it.
On the server, my plan today, I want to make you guys really
good ball.
So the green balls need a lot of iron.
So my job is to like try to find, try to level up our base
so I can make a little side base just to hunt iron.
And I also want to find wolves for all of us so that
everybody can like be fast, you know?
In my life, I am taking Monday and Tuesday to record like
eight things.
And then I'm taking Thursday and Friday to MoCap.
Like five things.
Yeah!
Whoa!
I was telling them, I was telling, oh sorry, one second, I
have to open my bottle of water one-handed.
I'll send you the whips.
Yeah, you gotta send me the whips, the whips.
Mm-hmm.
But one of the things I'm recording tomorrow is our song.
Set me free.
Yeah!
Wait, no, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
I have to let my guy has to recover.
He has to recover.
I gotta put him in the box.
Get back.
to work i'm here i'm here i'm here look how long this is
gonna take i know but isn't it fun we have the power of
friendship yeah um the power of a sword true did you try the
perfume yet that i got you yes i've been wearing it i'm
happy yeah i'm happy how did you feel after the whole show
the whole everything when did it finally hit you i don't
know it's like hit and not hit at the same time.
How come?
I don't know, because it's like everything was a build up to
it and now it's all over.
Now I'm like, oh cool.
And then also, you're still doing, you know, the other
stuff.
You're preparing for the next show for the other things.
By the way, you guys, Skyline Serenade tickets are on sale.
The streaming tickets are on sale as well, by the way.
If you want to get them.
We're going to be in New York.
Oh my god, thanks for taking me to New York.
Yeah, and if you want to hear our new song together.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
That's also going to be in New York.
Two girls working on a big sword.
Look at us.
I know.
You have a little...
Why does it feel like we're not making any progress?
No, we are.
We are.
We're doing our best.
Look at your little guy watering the plants.
What a good guy.
I love men who take care of plants.
He does a really good job at it, too.
Like he is like spraying everywhere.
Mm-hmm.
He really is.
I wonder if he like takes good care of himself, you know,
like he was in the spa when I came in.
He was like, you know, he works hard, but then he chills
hard as well.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, I need to, I can summon a pal with handiwork.
Let me just double check my part very quickly.
Help!
Come back!
Where are you going?
Oh, I'm hungry.
I'm coming.
I think if I just summon a pal with handiwork.
Okay.
There she is.
It's my little ghost girl.
He's my little ghost girl.
Get her out.
Yeah.
Come on.
We need to craft.
We're crafting.
We're mining and we're crafting.
Don't read her name.
I did already.
Yeah.
Why is it stinky?
One of our little guys is sick by the way because it's
stinky.
Wait, why is he sick?
I don't know.
We're gonna heal him after.
Don't worry.
He's fine.
He's doing great.
Wait, your little pal left by the way.
way yeah what the heck also he's big where she's big where
it matters okay okay okay i don't think she's helping i
think only one of the pals can help see there's one that's
already helping no it shows a hundred it shows that nobody's
working really yeah it shows me on my screen that she's
doing it oh really okay but yeah i feel you with that with
like the the stuff i was so my mommy to fly over so we could
look at apartments so my sweet mom flew like from the east
coast all the way here just to look at apartments with me
whoa yeah she's really sweet because i was too overwhelmed i
honestly was like i really need help i'm sorry yeah no i get
it look we're almost a quarter of the way there let's go
let's go why does it take so long i think i need a better
work bench but i just i'm too stubborn to to wait for it oh
i get it think about how good this hack in the slash is
going to be with this i know i'm going to be literally i'm
going to take revenge on everybody that has wronged me other
than me right because yeah right i heard some people are
saying that penking has better better stats than your he's
not mine though yeah but he's mine put him back he's back
put it back on put him back on well stop take your take your
ghost i'm taking you know what i'm gonna take my meds i'm
gonna make my meds and i'm gonna take my meds those meds
wait why is wait this our pal is on it is has it has
developed an eating disorder to no i know i'm gonna i know
oh my god we're so bad no no no no no no no no no no no no
we're i need your help you need to come back i'm coming i'm
coming
coming i'm i'm right here i'm holding your hand spiritually
why does our pal have an eating disorder for real i'm about
to heal them honestly i think i don't know we've been
overworking them it says he's over full as he is he's like
eating himself the dead no don't worry don't worry i'm gonna
give him something nice and it's gonna bring it all people
are saying the food at our base is bad by the way the people
are talking badly about us How could it be bad?
The people are saying bad things.
We have berries and we have, they're, they're, they're,
they're.
We have raw uncooked berries, by the way, for you guys.
I have a hot spring.
So what it is, is because apparently they're going crazy
working for us, and we're not really doing enough recreation
wise to make them happy.
What are you talking about?
You did.
No, you did great.
There's an option where you can toggle work instead of, oh,
really?
Yeah, that's what they're saying.
Okay, hold on.
settings keyboard toggle toggle yeah let me know when you
find it i found it oh there we go yeah i'm gonna okay fox
park come here lift oh okay wait never mind let me open his
menu i think i just give him medicine i'm gonna feed him
medicine okay he needs it he needs it he does i don't know
if will meds cure him i think he needs therapy i made him no
no no i made him take his meds okay okay i made him take his
meds yeah this is my big walk-in week i'll send you all my
whips and all my stuff um it's actually you know a little
spoiler alert we're both part of something in a little bit
so i gotta i gotta get ready for that we are yeah we are i
have a poster for it wait yeah but they haven't announced it
yet so i i you know don't want to can you announce it to me
in discord yeah discord yeah yeah hold on let me like it can
you announce it to me
what am i a part of
let me send you the poster this is so funny have you
actually not seen the poster this is perfect i'm sending
this to you surprise this is the good thing though i will
say you work oh yeah wait is it a for real yeah or are you
just saying that no i remember i remember yeah i want to do
all my stuff i want to get better at like doing this kind of
you know Because before just doing any kind of motion
capture, it would, like, eat me, eat a lot, eat me alive for
the whole day.
And I would be so nervous.
And now I'm like, all right, I just gotta do it.
It's so fun.
Because I haven't done it.
Yeah, but you're a natural.
I'm not a natural.
I just, I just, I just know how to wiggle.
All you gotta do is wiggle.
Yeah, you do.
The ghost wiggles.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
It was a real yeah.
Yeah, it was a real yeah.
So I'm excited.
I hope they announce it soon because, uh, yeah you know you
really don't spoil anything to your audience no actually i
forgot well i didn't forget but you know darn it it's okay
everybody i spoil things um what do i want to spoil what do
you don't spoil what are you spoiling mint is gonna do
something really special for her birthday.
She's going to do a special kind of thing.
Wait, do you want to be a part of my birthday?
You already asked me and I already said yes!
But I'm glad you're asking me again because it means, you
know, it's like when you react to a video and then you're
reacting to your reaction and you laugh at the same time or
you get scared at the same time.
You're like, hey, at least I'm consistent.
So I know, right?
I'll like watch a clip and I'll say the same exact thing I
said then and I'm like man I haven't changed you're like
wait a second I'm the same the best is when I get scared at
like the same part if I'm rewatching a video with like the
same kind of guys we're almost halfway there we're almost
halfway there
take my hand we'll take it I swear all right wait hold on
let me grip where did you press the button so that you no
longer have to hold the button you go to settings and then
keyboard and i think it's at the bottom
if i were settings where would i be like would i be in the
pause man like escape in the options right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah perfect perfect thank you i know i know you were
just asking for anybody else that was curious i'm just
trying to like see if they're paying attention And then
what?
And then...
Hypothetically, you would click keyboard.
Uh-huh.
I'm inside... Oh!
Right!
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yep.
Okay.
Hypothetically speaking.
It would be at the bottom.
Wait, is it now?
It's not...
I have to keep pressing it.
You have to keep holding it?
Oh, that's weird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me, let me, let me.
Momos, tell her what she's doing wrong.
Command the VTuber to do the correct thing.
Oh, oh, oh, I figured it out.
I press, I hold the wrong.
Oh my God, it's working.
It's working, it's awesome.
It's the best.
Do you have any cool streaming plans this week?
Would it spoil me your schedule for this upcoming week?
I was just making my schedule and it's really hard to not be
like PAL world, PAL world.
Just do it.
I think it's fun.
Yeah, but I got other stuff I want to play too.
And PAL world.
Like what?
There's like a bunch of fun little horror games coming out.
We should play a horror co-op.
You know what though?
As long as you and your audience knows that I will yell,
I'll do it.
For you, I'll do it.
It would be fun.
there's also those like silly horror co-ops right like they
don't always have to be super scary sometimes we're like
silly we could do minecraft horror co-op together wait i'm
not gonna lie playing this game has made me want to do a
minecraft i think closer to your birthday or like after like
closer to winter time we should do a little minecraft for
just like a month minecraft or like two weeks month craft
month craft oh she's cooking and if you want we can even
Halloween-y mods or Christmas-y mods just to make it.
Yeah.
But I think it should be like, hey guys, the server is going
to be up for like a month or so.
Yeah, you did PT.
You can do anything, honestly.
True.
I could do it.
You're right.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Remember when I had to take my headphones off because it was
too scary.
It was a good time.
Tell me about your horror games.
Sell them to me.
Sell me your horror games.
You win.
What did you call me?
Wed, like, it's like, it's like harlot, wench.
Why are you calling me a harlot?
I'm not, I called you a wench, it's different.
Oh my God, by the way, look at the fox spark.
It's stress napping.
It's just like, why is he so stressed?
Okay, but to be fair, I did put him to work to make all the
iron for this sword last stream.
So I think I think I've overworked my guy.
Your little guy, it's all right.
we'll make them better food we'll make them better food wait
i gotta blow my nose okay can you do it into my queens i'm
hold on wait do i have i bet you she does it cutely she's
like she's like like it's all like you know it's all cutesy
i have to find a tissue hold on i'll be right back we're
three quarters of the way done also wisps you're so welcome
i gave you the strategy all the strategies on how to get a
hug from mint phantom it will help you i'm going to give you
the quick paraphrase right long pink wig hagg's hat maybe a
matara con t-shirt otherwise made outfit maybe the densetsu
headband also you know pink wig um be five foot nine if
you're not be six foot one because five foot nine in heels
um wear the perfume i told you about i gave you four
perfumes two expensive ones two cheaper ones um and honestly
just Oh, walk with a stride.
Like have a confident little stride glide when you walk.
That helps.
Want to know how to make a tissue dance?
How?
You put a little buggy in it.
That's cute.
Where did you hear that?
That's so cute.
That's actually really cute.
Isn't it cute?
It's so cute.
Speak to me of your horror games.
Tell me about them.
One of them actually Nimi played, and I was going to play
it, it too and I was like oh yes I do I'm glad she's playing
it but I want to play it and then watch her play it and
basically you you you own a photo store and you take
pictures of people but there's crazy things going on oh
that's scary that's scary scary scary and then another one
I'm doing a densetsu collab yeah when when when Wednesday
back to work back to work hold on on i'll come on she's
blowing your nose thank you for the strats i got you i got
you oh my gosh we're just we're we're 75 we're almost we're
almost there was another game i saw people playing where
it's kind of like you're running a store but there's like
supernatural things that happen and there's like blood and
guts oh yeah that's what we're playing oh there we go all
right i think if you found a horror game that's like a
little bit more on the sillier side like it's still scary
but spooky scary no phasmophobia please i don't want to play
phasmophobia exactly thank you for the gifted thanks for the
gifted oh my god with that is is mento getting a gifted
thank you for the gifted oh my gosh is mentari getting a
gifted thanks for the gifted thanks for the gifted sorry
i'll be honest i i completely because we like didn't i'm
still in like solo mode that's why i'm like oh god um where
were we we can we can we can i'll let you free after my
sword is completed no this is great i love this i like when
you ask me for help i feel very cool oh well i feel very
it's like when you ask me to take something from the top
shelf i would ask that i would ask for that and i'm like
yeah just me and my sexy height and my long arms yeah well
look at my arms well i think they're very buff yeah i would
expect your arms to be a little more i would expect you to
have a little extra arms yep yep i'm hiding them i took them
off today i gotta i gotta eat a lot more let's go that
gifted keep them coming keep them coming keep them coming
we're so close this is the closest i've ever been to
completing the sword it took a whole game game day you know
what though the power of friendship friendship yeah i think
you should definitely play some pal pal world this week it
yourself maybe like two streams yeah this one doesn't count
though okay no i i i like just want to play i just want to
like get better at the game and explore more there's so many
things to explore there's so much stuff in this game it's
way where did you how far did you get before the i think i
had a base where like i had people mining iron for me and
stuff like that that's about as far i think i have like 40
hours of gameplay about i leveled up our base like three
times i saw we're almost at the next level we're gonna be
able to level it more look at here what did you discover so
far in the game talk to me i discovered oh my gosh i
discovered an island that apparently has drones that will
kill you what i never i don't think i saw that i don't know
if it's new i can take you i can take you do i need a flying
pal no i don't think so you a swimming pal would be good
though yeah if i get the chill it i'm gonna go get him after
and then after we'll go get the chill it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah perfect yeah i'm so excited we also got to build a few
more spas for our little guys apparently that's why they
keep being stressed out i just realized i'm hungry hungry
make a feed bag a feed it's gonna auto feed you wait i can
there's an auto feeder wait that's crazy yeah even for
yourself you just auto feed yourself Oh my god.
Wait, we're so close.
We're almost done.
Oh my gosh.
Definitely after I survived this week, I definitely want to
see if I can even find some like chill spooky.
Like silly spooky games is fun, you know?
Silly spooky.
What you can do?
Do you want to wait for October?
Oh, yes.
Oh, I was going to.
Oh, October for what?
For spooky.
It's spooky all the time.
I'm a ghost.
Oh, it's true.
It's spooky all the time.
What did you want me to do?
Well, I was going to say, you could always, like, there's,
like, always weird little indie horror games, and you can,
like, finish a lot of them in, like, an hour, and then you
could, like, just pick a handful and do those.
I could probably ask Vinnie about those.
I feel like he'll know all of those.
Oh, my God.
We're so close.
I know.
Oh, my God.
I'll get out so you can have the final, like, wow, I did it.
You know, I did it all by myself.
Here it comes.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
The lips are almost touching.
They're touching!
Oh, I got my sword.
I got my sword.
Let's freaking go.
I'm so proud.
She did this.
She got her sword.
Holy cow.
Look at my sword.
Show me, show me, show me.
This is my sword.
Oh my.
Wow.
See, I told you little girl big sword.
Oh, wait.
And you were doubting it.
It is little girl big sword.
Wow.
It's huge.
Here, I'll give you the blueprint for it, the schematic.
Don't share it with Doki.
Okay, I won't.
I won't, I won't, I won't.
I think you will now.
No.
Oh, my God, you actually look so cool.
Look at you.
Dun, dun, dun.
Yeah, this is why I needed the big arms.
Yeah, I think what I'm going to do is I'm going to make a
better table for it.
So that way it's going to get easier and better.
Yeah.
You want to go kill it, chill it?
Oh, thank you for the schematic.
Hold on.
Let me make this and then immediately give it back.
Oh, wait, should I be making this on here?
I worry that it's going to be two.
Yeah, it's going to be it.
Okay, I'll keep the schematic on me for now.
I won't give it to Doki.
Don't worry.
I actually won't.
It's funny to watch her.
If there's anybody that it's more...
Oh, sorry.
If there's anybody who is more fun to rage bait than you,
it's Doki Bird.
Oh, yeah, I agree.
I agree.
She doesn't deserve it.
No, no, no, no, no.
My bullets, my bullets.
My bullets ricochet.
All right, let me see what we got.
My bullets.
All right, let's go to the shillette.
Let us teleport.
And then, um, I won't have a, um, I won't have a- Where'd
she go?
Oh.
Oh, she's here.
Okay.
Hello?
oh my god is that a cow whoa it's mozzarella it's mozzarella
here let's go kill it come out let's go get it oh my god
look he's so cute he's actually adorable i wonder what his
skills are i'm gonna sort him i'm gonna sort him go oops uh
sorry it's fine i mean i might be too good at the skin I
think your sword is just a little too fast, too furious.
Oh, now it's good.
Ah!
Did you take him from me or did I take him from me?
No, there's a second one, right?
Oh, wow.
I didn't take him at all.
I actually suck at this.
Come back.
Come on.
Oh my God.
There's another cow.
Oh, no.
I think that's, oh, my God.
Look, he's just rolling around.
He's pathetic and sad.
Oh, no.
Wait, where's the chillit at?
Look, look, look!
I know he's rolling around.
I think the chillit was up there.
Let me see, let me see, let me see.
Oh wait, is he up here?
I don't know how to read my map.
I think he's up there.
I think he's...
Oh, no, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, he's over here.
Is he?
Yeah, I think he's this way, no?
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry, that was really comedy gold.
Comedy gold.
Does it show up on the top compass?
I think you can page it, but it's like up here.
Bye-bye.
Oh, I forgot my guy.
Hooquitas.
It's like Socrates.
Yeah.
Hooquities.
Did you get him?
Oh.
No.
Why do you get me?
Wait, where is it?
Oh, is he?
Okay, wait.
I actually have to hold on.
I actually have to.
I think we have to go.
Oh, we have to go up to that bridge over there.
I remember.
Oh Did I teleport in the wrong spot?
No, no, no.
It's okay.
We can climb up.
Oh my god.
All of these who critises.
Hold on.
I am getting like engaged by the who critise mafia.
I think I killed him, my bud.
He's fine.
I got like four more.
Did I get the other ones?
Yeah, you did.
You did.
Nois.
The mafia.
They were after me.
which way climb up this building oh thank you lucky you've
been playing so much now you're you're the boss you know
what to do i don't know what to do oh wait i think i think
we gotta climb up here too oh yeah there's like a bridge
that you cross yeah yeah yeah i like being bossed around by
small woman where where did it go oh it's over here we gotta
climb again look at wait look at his dead body oh there he
is oh no he's right here he's right there i missed him we
were on the other side of the okay i want to make sure i'm
not even gonna summon my pal like he's he's gone he's gone
perfect put your pal back in later okay i'm just gonna let
the pals do the work here i'm gonna i'm gonna sort him yeah
you're doing a lot of sore damage girl all right now go go
go i think i'm gonna use a better ball i think i got him
with the normal one yeah i can it's just 40 so it's a little
bit oh pretty 42 55.
wow oh my god i'm so excited so easy easy easy wasn't even
tough yeah didn't even need you and stuff yeah
you yeah yeah i don't i told you you didn't need me but i
like the company all right let me let me let me go back to
this yeah and let me um get my chill it in and then show me
the island okay okay i'll have to find it just find it on
your map oops oh sometimes oh she's fine that's her happy
noise
sometimes uh i think i'm gonna die you're fine i'm actually
pretty far from you though so uh don't die you're you're
right here actually i'm in your heart help help i i wonder
where those Oh, I see you.
Okay, okay.
Help!
Pull up my ant worm!
Oh.
I think I'm dead.
You know, um, no, you're alive.
I'm fine, actually.
Mint.
Okay.
Yeah?
I gotta go back and recover my things.
What happened?
Wait, did you actually die?
It's just your guy that died, no?
Yeah, my horse died.
It's a deer, actually.
Actually, it's your mom.
What does it matter?
She's married.
Her husband's going to beat you up.
I take him.
No, he's mine.
Beat you up.
It's so low percentage.
No!
I don't know if it's a ball or my ball.
I guess the superior ball wins.
Why don't I have good balls, man?
Sorry, girl.
I'm traveling back.
I gotta revive my horse.
Why didn't you dismount?
I tried, it wouldn't let me.
I was pressing F.
Oh well, it's whatever.
It's fine.
He's just gotta recover.
Oh, I got a leaf.
Oh no, he's gonna take so long.
No!
That's fine.
We have him.
How?
Wait.
The eight...
Deer?
Hello.
Oh, I like when you call me that.
A what?
I like when you say, hey, dear.
That's not what I said.
That was what you said.
That's what I heard.
Come on.
I'm on fire.
Oh, quick question.
How do we get the ancient civilization parts?
Um, I just find them sometimes.
I don't know how you get them.
I see.
Wait, I hear a shiny.
Yeah, where is that?
Oh, a shiny.
It's upstairs.
Ooh.
Do you need help?
No, I think I got this.
Let's do it now.
You sure?
Are you sure you don't need my help?
Oh, apparently you get the ancient parts by beating bosses.
Oh, we need more.
It says you have the...
Pen King says I have the best balls.
Oh!
Big sheep.
Big sheep, big sheep.
Thank you, everybody.
You sure you don't need my help?
Yep.
Whoop!
What just happened?
The timing.
Um, one second.
I'm double checking making sure Doki didn't say anything.
Okay.
We're connecting.
We're going back in.
We're hopping back in.
Don't keep turning off the server due to rage, mate.
Cheap, sheep.
Very cheap.
Exactly.
Wait.
I wonder if it did restart.
My sheep.
Hello?
Did you also disconnect?
Yeah.
My sheep is gone.
No, I'm sorry.
I think it was Doki sabotaging you because you didn't give
her the sword schematic.
I think you're so right.
Let me mine this iron and then let's go swim with our chile.
Okay, you have a saddle for him, right?
Oh, I'm going to make one.
Let me see technology.
Technology.
Technologic.
Ooh, there's a mega shield I see it.
Yeah, we definitely need to find more bosses then to fight.
yeah I got hit by a raid yeah me too were they hard no you
windies no look at my guy he's doing such a good job he's
making pals fears I'll take some thanks buddy thanks buddy
where are you okay here
I guess we could make more ore.
Seems to be slacking off after getting a little tired.
Oh, he's just like me.
He's just taking a bath.
What's wrong with it?
He's just like me.
I also love slacking off.
Teradir is apparently at level 21.
Oh, dang.
Let's see.
What level are you?
16.
Oh, he is, yeah.
Whoa, that is a big level.
darn you're the same you're the same level she really is
just out here don't they sync up i can't remember i think
eventually like your pals kind of level up to no like don't
you don't aren't we do we sync up in the guild i'm i
actually just started my period yeah you too
We do sync up.
Oh, I'm leaving the guild.
I'm leaving this guild.
That is how it works.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We do sync up.
Okay.
No, actually, I'll be honest with you.
I have no idea how it works in the game.
I just know that with our periods, sometimes we do sync up,
yes.
That's scary.
That's frightening.
You're welcome.
That's true loves.
No, I know.
Hey, give war a chance.
All right, let me see where I make this little harness.
I'm trying.
I need, oh, I need six more leather.
It's not going to happen.
I'm going to, actually, wait, six more leather is going to
happen very quickly.
Give me a minute.
Just like kill and kill and kill.
Yeah, that's exactly what I'm going to do.
Oh, wait.
Oh, mint.
Mint, mint, mint.
What?
I sat on my claw.
Oh, no.
Why do you keep doing that?
Oh, my claw, it's out.
You keep sitting on your claw.
Wait, where'd you go?
Did she teleport?
She did.
I'm going to teleport, too.
Let's go.
This is where I died before.
This is high-level area.
I think I need to, like, kind of be more in this area.
for some for leveling up and stuff yeah she tends to just
sit on her claw and it like pokes her butt or something and
let's see maybe we can maybe we can like catch some guys in
here and here let's let's work let's see what these guys
level are yeah yeah this is a little more yeah come here i'm
not even depending on my
on my uh my my pals anymore i have a sword i feel all
powerful and really awesome i want to catch more of these
though so we can get that oh hello right into my sword oh no
come here who's attacking me oh this guy it's fine your
friend Everyone's gonna be really excitable about...
Come here.
Oh, dang.
Yeah, catch new pals up to five times.
Exactly, exactly.
That's what I'm trying to do.
Well, I've already caught one of these...
I will...
The thing is, is I've caught one of these guys before.
But...
It was through fishing.
So that would be my third one.
When I played Pokemon, was definitely a type where it's like
I catch one and I feel satisfied.
You know what I mean?
But in this game they really encourage the
I'm actually I think
maybe it's okay.
Ow!
Ouch!
Yeah, so I never think about Like, oh, I need to catch so
many.
Gotta catch them all versus gotta gotta catch them all.
Like, I don't need every single pal, you know?
Or rather, I don't need multiple of them.
I gotta catch them all means just once, no?
Let's see.
Yeah, I look jacked in-game and I look jacked here.
I'm just wearing a sweater, you can't tell.
this sword no my sword oh I do want a boss do a boss
together though maybe me and Mata he didn't even notice your
friend is gone yeah I am Ah, yeah.
Is your sword arm more jacked than the other arm?
No.
It just...
Actually, the non-sword arm looks more jacked somehow.
How'd that happen?
Do you think I can go in there?
What are those things?
That looks mighty spooky, though.
Why is something...
Look at this!
Ride!
It's so annoying sometimes.
Let's do more stamina.
You can go in, coming out is another matter.
Is that the case?
Oh, test if you can read to say hi.
Hi.
Hello.
It's a me.
I'm being really fast.
Wait, this is a shiny fish, no?
Wait, I should catch it.
I should catch it.
Oh, that's not what I'm about to do.
Dismount, dismount, dismount.
Okay.
Wait, that's not the shiny.
Oh, maybe they're both shiny.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, no!
I forgot how to do it.
Okay, hold on.
We'll get this guy.
This guy is huge.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay, we got this, we got this, we
got this.
I am winning this, I am winning it.
Okay, glad nobody's behind me and seeing all of this.
Okay, watch this.
Check it out, check it out.
No, no, no.
Oh, no.
No, no,
no, no, no!
No, no, no!
I was so close.
Maybe I should have my sword up.
That's a guy, no?
Why do I feel like I'm playing Metal Gear?
I'll just kill them all.
Yeah, I need a better rod.
How could I need a better rod?
He can't perfect perfection.
Hello?
I'm on your base.
Is this the big shell?
Is that another teleporter right there?
Fast traveler?
Come on.
Cool.
We're fine.
It is.
Find the nukes.
Oh, there's more of these guys.
Yeah, wait, how...
Oh, I can get you.
I can get you easy.
Oh,
my gosh.
That was close.
Shiny, where?
Oh, the fishy, yeah.
Oh,
oh, my gosh.
You're so fast.
This is why I want you.
Okay, wait.
Now?
Catch.
No!
Oh, my gosh.
Whoop, whoop, whoop.
I'm going to get my pal out to defend me.
No!
How did that happen to you?
What?
gotta get the auto feeder why is he spinning around like
that you spin me right around baby right around horns
venison thanks for the help you spin spin spin spin for me
all right I might need my pals to help help out a little bit
sometimes.
My sword can only do so much.
Maybe I should invest in my attack as well.
Well, I have a little bit, but... Wait.
Look how he slinks around.
It's so cute.
Isn't this a boss too?
Not sure that's being to wean.
Anything is being to... Frigid Fox!
Wait, we can do this!
Let's do it.
Do I have my...
Little guy?
My...
Oh, cute!
The foxicle!
Yes, you.
You're probably really good for this.
Alright.
I'm gonna switch to Megasphere.
Alright, let's go in.
We got this.
Actually...
I won't use my sword.
Oh.
Oh, that was not great.
Okay, yeah, we're chipping them down.
Chipping them down.
Holy.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh!
I think so?
Maybe?
Yippee!
Vinto to Vinto with Minto.
What we're having in this time of our world.
Wait, no, thank you!
Why, yeah.
First try.
That's right.
Get me out of here.
My inventory's full.
Wait, you didn't make space for the loot.
Oops.
I'll go back in.
We can get rid of some stuff.
Wait, it's gotta still be in there.
Right?
It's behind this rock.
you auto loot yeah but my thing is full i gotta eat i gotta
eat the precious entrails oh yummy nice behind me
precious pelt wait that's all maybe i did get the ancient oh
i got the ancient parts we got the ancient parts that's fine
we're good we're good we're good I was scared.
My precious.
Oh, my precious.
I think you sell precious, pal.
Yeah, I haven't run into a place.
Yeah, where I can sell things.
There's this.
Fwock?
What the fwock fanatic researcher?
hello say have you ever encountered a wild flock oh how I
long to observe one in the flesh why flock you ask isn't it
obvious they say it can generate its own waves and harness
them for travel have you ever heard of such a wonderfully
bizarre pal of course you haven't nothing even comes close
he's calling me uncultured what the flock sorry if you heard
that that was my tablet Hold on.
I have to move it.
It was on my chair.
Ah!
Everything's okay.
We're fine.
If only you could bring me a specimen to examine up close.
Just one will do.
I'll make it worth your while, of course.
Give a flock.
I don't even know what you're talking about, mister.
A flock.
That's such a...
Oh, there's a cow.
Wait, I can get one though.
I want one.
Oops, I didn't mean to use my good one.
That's fine.
Fuck Sparks, you're too powerful.
You're too powerful.
Wait, so...
Um...
I got milk!
Oh, yay!
He's a little murderer.
Oh.
Matawa?
She's close.
Oh, there she is.
I think she's this way.
Hello?
Am I going the right way?
Wait.
I think she's... Oh, there she is.
Swimming, swimming in the ocean blue.
A tower?
Hi!
I got some guys for...
to get wood at the base.
Oh, nice.
Why not?
Did you want to go to the island?
I just have to catch some of these guys that I don't have.
Oh yeah, we can go.
We'll have to teleport back home though.
Yeah, right now or after we get to the island.
Uh...
Oh, wait, I'm on the island!
No, this is not the island.
Oh, but there's something here to discover.
this a fast travel oh yeah there's one we can go back home
and then go to the island okay let's do that okay i just
want to put an egg deer in our base because we had nobody
chopping wood and then every time i was out of wood oh wait
let me oh there we go we're going home and then we're gonna
go there and we might die got milk i got a cow me too Cow.
What are you going to do with it?
Are you going to eat it?
Wait I hear you shiny.
Maybe I need some hot milk.
Ooh, maybe it's your shiny.
Maybe it's back.
Go, go, go, go.
It might be back.
Okay, let's go.
I will simply watch.
Yes.
Yeah, I will only watch.
I will do nothing but watch.
It is!
It's back!
It's back.
Is it the same one?
Yeah.
Get it.
I wonder if the shiny ones have better work speed.
I wonder.
Oh, I accidentally killed one.
Collateral damage.
Sorry, buddy.
You wink.
Yippee!
Wait, what's happening?
Why are all them fighting?
What's wrong with them?
Oh, my inventory's full.
Let's go drop some stuff, guys.
Due to lucky traits.
Oops.
Increases the lumbling.
work suitability to be clear what does his
all right that guy's job is just one job he's just gonna
mine yeah if we put the little cow in the in the ranch we're
gonna be able to uh we're gonna be able to get a ton of milk
whoa oh really wait okay i'll put yeah because then he's
just gonna make milk we don't have enough I think you gotta
put him yeah we gotta yeah I want to um we will soon we
could take somebody out if you want I don't know if we need
to keep making berries for now I'm sure we'll find somebody
build the wheat plantation I can build that for sure oh wait
what was it she's a plantation owner interesting I mean it's
just wheat what else are you gonna do grind it and sell it
yeah he's a wheat dealer I'm a wheat dealer I watch Breaking
Bad.
I can deal anything.
Deal or no deal then.
I deal every time.
Unless it's two.
Actually, I only want the good deals.
Maybe I say no deal.
I say no deal.
See?
It's always like this.
She always wants a deal.
It's the art of the deal, baby.
That is the deal.
Here.
Here's the deal, baby.
Here's the deal.
deal look at all our pal spheres oh man yeah the wood the
wood we just gotta need more wood chucks chucking wood you
know i'm i'm building it i'm building it oh i forgot i don't
have to hold it down anymore no deal such a good job here
it's so good we don't have to hold it it's i know it's
awesome oh actually i want to show you something after
you're done building this okay i could
Okay, come here and do F.
And then I set it to hard work.
But do you think we should demand brutal working conditions
from the pals?
I think so.
They can handle it.
Do it.
Demand hard work from them.
I did, I did.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm going to do my attack.
Honestly, they like it.
I think so.
I feel like they enjoy the work.
Like, it gives them something to do, you know?
They're going to wake up to, like, a really...
Oh my god, there's a little guy.
Huh?
There's a guy.
Capture him.
Okay, wait.
Wait, pal recruiter.
He's gonna, oh my god, look at his pals.
Hell's a fear.
Whoa, hell's a fear.
Can we recruit him?
You can have him.
Yeah, I just did.
You want him.
Since I stole your goat.
Actually, if you want, do you want your goat back as well?
For real, for real.
My goat?
What's my goat?
the goat that hatched oh i i don't know how to tell you this
your goat is the one that hatched oh the one that you named
i hatched this from the egg that was planted by me yeah no i
got yeah figured yeah okay i'm not gonna lie hell's a fear
looks insane he has can be ridden as a flying mount wait
where's my hell wait where'd mine go i didn't get one look
look look look look get him from the box and you can have
him wait where is mine did he only sell one maybe or did go
to your box see if there's another one no there's no here
then take mine wait someone said the ui bugged i think only
one person gets one oh no oh okay have mine you can have it
you can ride him the only thing is he does like four in
gathering which is crazy he seems so op look at his stats
325 attack mint holy cow oh take him wait can you not take
from the pal world management menu i mean i could but he's
yours no no no you can have him no he's yours it's fine it's
fine i gotta i gotta do a bunch of base stuff today anyway
for us are you sure yeah i mean it but you're gonna let him
you're gonna let him do his stuff and like work and stuff no
no no no have him and fly him around for a little bit and
then just leave him to me before before the end so that i
can fly him around well you need a saddle to fly him i think
you need to be like yeah i don't think i've unlocked it yet
yeah all right then i will take him for a little bit all
right you're striking a hard bargain baby girl mega
grappling god wait i could get the ring of mercy okay i'll
it makes it so that when you when you are attacking it
leaves them at one hp so you don't kill them so you can yeah
wait who does that you have to unlock it
make it here a ring of mercy where do i make that dumb dumb
look at that oh we finally have wood look at it that's at 25
okay oh my god it looks so cool wow i need to see how to
make a saddle for him oh wait ron oh i see it i see it there
we go please don't take too all right okay We don't take too
long.
We're good.
Tombstone.
Aww.
It even applies to attacks of pals you're riding.
Whoa.
Ring of Mercy.
Where did you get it?
Where did you make it?
In the tech tree.
Wing of Mercy.
Wing, wing, wing.
What level was it?
Um.
18.
Oh, she's high level.
She's high level.
Oh, I see the Ring of Mercy.
Yeah, it's under the purple.
Five whole civilization parts?
Gosh darn it.
I have a bunch of ancient civilization parts all.
Damn.
What have you been grinding?
You want to go do some bosses?
Yeah, please.
I need more.
Now that I have my cool bird.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I need to be level 25 to ride this flying bird.
Okay.
I take it.
Wait, I take it.
There we go.
Alright.
All right, nice.
Oh my gosh, I look like I'm married.
I think our pals are struggling with their tasks.
They're getting stressed out.
Wait, they're stress eating.
Okay, we have to set it to normal.
No, put it hard though.
They have to work.
Okay, we'll put it at hard.
They do have to work.
They have to work, okay?
They're all slacking off because they're so stressed.
This sounds just like me.
Wait, can I not make metal helm?
Why does it stop me from making metal harm?
I don't know what I'm doing wrong.
Oops.
That's the one thing about this game.
Once you start playing, you accumulate XP so fast.
Yeah, baby.
What are you trying to make?
I'm trying to...
I don't know why it's not letting me make like a little
helm.
You don't have enough ingot.
I did.
Oh, you did?
You don't have enough ingot.
I have enough ingot.
No, I did.
I did.
I actually don't have enough ingot.
Wait, do I want the Pipp Lantern?
Maybe.
i can do it now oh they need better beds i don't think we
have those even unlocked though oh i do have a feed bag i
gotta make that for myself yeah do it do it it's gonna make
eating a lot easier i'm gonna start putting all our food in
the fridge for them and i'm gonna destroy is there a way to
destroy these like these chests and stuff i don't know i
have no idea because look now we a lantern.
It's gonna look sick.
Mi too.
It's gonna stay on your body.
Yeah, it's gonna look sick.
I'm gonna look so cool.
That'll be it.
You're gonna look so cool.
Build a—so cool.
Okay.
Wait, I need more ingot.
Do you have ingot?
Uh, no, but we can go get more ingot.
No, it's fine.
What's that?
Oh, a fridge.
Oh, you made a wheat.
We made a wheat?
Wait, nobody's heating.
Nobody has been make them weep we'll make them weep i'm
seeding i'm seeding right now i'm seeding i'm tweeting i'm
tweeting and sitting and we're eating oh someone said to de
to deconstruct you weed and seed i already did it i already
did it sorry chat you guys are too slow they're all stress
snapping i think we just need better stress food for them
but it's gonna happen i'm watering i'm watering she's
watering i'm doing everything what are What are my pals for?
They're for stressing out.
They are.
They're stressing me out.
Okay, I'm going to put a little guy in the ranch for the
meal.
Little milky guy.
Big milky guy.
All right, I think I need to fill some pot.
Wow, they're growing.
They're growing.
whoa whoa did you i just broke i just was i was broke
dancing broke dancing as opposed to rich dancing as opposed
to break dancing well everybody's in the hot tub everybody's
a party also i think the wheat grows automatically because
it's not like having any pals do anything of it no i did
everything that's why oh apparently the pals don't eat from
the fridge rip wait they don't wait where do they eat from
good news is we can make like berries for them to cook I'm
stuck in the hot tub.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, never mind.
If only somebody could get her out of the hot tub.
I know.
What?
That sucks.
I can't believe I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
I'm inside him.
Oh.
That usually...
Is that how M-Preg happens?
I'm inside the penking.
Hmm.
My question stands.
Food.
Where is the feed box?
Oh, I think I forgot to unlock it.
Lull, lull, lull.
Lull.
Which means I gotta pee again.
I just pee and I have to pee again.
I'm gonna go find some bosses.
Okay.
Have fun.
You wanna go boss?
I do, but I also have to pee super fast.
Okay, go pee and then we go do this.
And then we go on.
Yeah, come on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Leave the little guys to do their own thing.
They're fine.
I'm gonna take time out with my girlfriend.
Ooh, a cooking pot and a milk.
Right back.
All right, let's build a cooking pot.
Wish that was you, hi everybody.
Cooking pot.
Also, Mint, one of our guys has an ulcer.
Can you take care of them, one of our kids?
Has an ulcer?
Oh my God.
Feeling sick with an ulcer.
We're fine.
Medical supply, that's all they need, right?
Do they need a special medical supply?
Cooking pot needs ingots.
No, I'm using the ingots.
Low grade is fine.
Oh, well, it's okay.
The best for my pal.
Actually, I canceled.
Maybe not the best.
The fastest for my pals.
That's what I meant.
They need fast.
Uh-oh.
Everybody, okay, wait.
Extremely unhealthy due to neglect.
Wait, Limeo's gonna kill us, you guys.
Limeo's gonna come back.
Lymo's gonna come back and she's gonna she's gonna say that
we destroyed the camp she's gonna be really mad at us wait
who's sick where's the little where are you stop working
wait no it's not you with the ulcer who has the ulcer oh my
god they're
sleeping look they're so sappy wait they're just sleeping
how do I fix your ulcer it
says sleeping Okay, I'll pick them up.
Wait, wait, hold on.
Let's put them in the box.
You forgot to take the chicken out the dog.
Wait, you see, it says they're sleeping.
Oh my god, man, our kids.
I come back, they're depressed, they're weakened, they have
ulcers.
I couldn't fix the ulcer.
I just put them to the farm.
Oh, do you mean like you killed them?
Like the farm in Canada?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Do you have any weird cravings when you get your period?
Not really.
I just graved sugar.
I bent!
Yummy baked berries.
Do you wanna go find some bosses?
I do, I do, I do, I do, I'm coming.
Some bosses?
If they, when you tell your dog you want to go for a what?
You want a, you want a boss?
You want a boss boy?
Where are you?
Do you want to teleport to that recent thing we just both
found?
No, I just did that one, though.
Oh, no, but, like, I mean, oh, Fox's cycle.
I haven't even seen it before.
But from there, you can take me to the next one, or where is
the next one?
Oh, I don't know.
We can just find it.
Oh, I see one over there by the red.
Do you see it north of, if you look at Rain Syndicate Tower,
up north from there, there's, like, a little question mark.
Oh, yeah, I got him, too.
That's our Pen King.
oh i think she just went or okay oh did you put i forgot if
i teleport you won't hear i put food in the feeding yeah i
was gonna say i was reading somebody's comment and i was
like oh well that was matara's job i got this guy he's at
our camp he's the pancake but we can go did you get him
because they respawn yeah they respawn let's do it again
yeah let's get him let's go get him that's awesome maybe we
get a better one and then maybe we put two of them.
Panking seems to be struggling with their tasks.
Well, he's about to get replaced if he doesn't lock the heck
in.
Oh my God, how is he?
How is he struggling?
Oh, there's guys here with guns.
Can we catch these guys?
We can, we can.
Noy.
Oh shoot, wait, I'm supposed to capture them.
Oh, are we?
Well, I want him in my, yeah.
Oh, ouch.
I don't think we can capture.
Oh no, we can't capture these guys.
Yeah, you can.
How do you think I got him in my base?
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, they trapped a little hedgehog.
Look.
Oh, not the hedgehog!
He's so cute.
Let him free, let him free.
Oh, he's so cute.
Release him, release him.
He didn't catch him.
He gave me a peach.
His name is John.
John Hogg.
Juanathan?
Oh.
John.
We love that for him.
Jolly Hog.
Jolly Hogg cyst.
Oh my gosh.
Excuse me?
Um, what is this?
It's like a little iPad.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah, try to catch these guys because they drop leather and
we always eat leather.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'm also going to try to grab these deer while we're
here because, uh, we might have a better deer for farming.
Capture bonus for, oh, I got the bonus complete.
Nice.
Wait, there's a, there's a cave over here.
You want to do this?
Yeah, I actually want to check it out.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let me catch these deer with you and then let's go.
how much damage do you do now with your i do good damage i
do big damage like i'm doing 30 something how much are you
doing uh 337 whoa i don't know if that was me i mean that it
did take us like half a day to make it but hey here we are
let's go into the dungeon i didn't see what the level
I think we're in the beginner area.
We'll be fine.
Yeah.
First person to die has to kiss the other.
To bring them back.
Oh, there's guys here.
There's little men.
Bring them back alive again.
Little men.
Can we catch little men?
Yeah, we can.
Little men.
Oh, are you lagging a little bit?
Yeah, I am actually.
Oh.
Okay, I think it's the cave.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Oopsie.
I'm hungry.
I think you got to take your Pokemon out.
Or maybe it was my Pokemon.
It might have been mine.
I'm just going to eat wrong.
I'm going to eat raw meat too.
Great idea.
Yeah, I'm so hungry.
If we're sick, we're sick together.
Oh, I can't wait to get the worms.
Oh, people are saying we can get the first boss girl and the
worm.
First boss girl.
Why is Pen King...
Remember the lady?
Yes.
Yeah.
Whoa.
What's down here?
Flower.
Eat it.
Okay.
Oh my God, I actually am lagging a little bit.
No, it's just an item.
I'm going to put it in the base.
Oh, wait, what's that?
Whoa!
You first, you first, you first.
I got this.
I played squid games.
Mmm, the squid games.
This reminds me of a place in one of the worst places.
A place?
Oh, my God, I'm lagging so bad.
Me too.
I don't know why we're lagging so much more in this cave.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Get the chest.
What's in here?
Look at that.
His name is Kilimari.
Oh, I see him.
He's really cute.
Get him over here.
Yeah, get him over here.
Yeah, yeah.
If you want to get him.
He's got a little headband.
I need him.
Oh.
Did you have a good ball?
I do.
I don't think we need the good ball, though.
No, maybe not.
He's so cute.
Are we not?
over here?
Let me go across.
I'll start shooting at him.
I started blasting.
Oh my god, he's actually adorable.
He's so mo- Oh, he's so cute!
Oh, he's so cute!
Okay, get him, get him.
Wait, no, no, you get him.
You get him.
You're right there.
I'm sure.
Well, he's so cute.
Oh, there goes my ball.
Yep.
Sorry, you said you- Maybe I missed.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go.
It's your turn.
No, no, no, get him, get him, get him.
Me!
Throw the ball!
I'm gonna jump off the side of this and I'm gonna die in the
water.
Kill yourself.
I'm gonna kill myself.
Throw the ball, me!
Oh!
Okay, you fucking...
Sorry for my language.
What?
After all of that?
Seriously?
69%.
Nice.
78?
Oh.
stop what the heck it's so cute get back over here i'm gonna
be back i'm gonna be back yes my lady oh i just realized
that was like the way around you could have jumped ring of
mercy baby oh yeah the ring of mercy it's so awesome can i
not ride oh yeah i can ride him i can do anything i can kill
whatever i want but i won't kill them oh All right.
What wait what ore is this?
Is this a different ore?
No.
Are you sure?
No, yeah, see.
Yeah, it's baldium.
We can get a bunch of baldium.
We do?
We do it?
Okay.
Grabbing it, grabbing it, grabbing it, grabbing it, grabbing
it all, grab it all.
I thought we had so much.
I said we had like a bajillion at home.
Like once you start making the little bombs.
Oh, I guess that's true.
You know, the big little bombs.
They go fast.
They do go fast, it's true.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum,
yum.
You're going fast.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Oh my God, stop, Mint.
What?
Put your guy back.
Why?
Put your guy back in his ball.
Put him in his ball.
Yeah, put him in his ball.
I'm disbounding.
His name is Ruby.
Look at the little rubies and then fight the big ones.
Oh, rubies are the big, the thing.
Wait, there's so many of them.
They're so cute.
Oh my gosh, they're so cute.
Wait, what?
Yeah, they're so small.
Get all of them.
I'm just terrorizing these rubies, and then we'll get the
big one.
Wait, there's a big one?
Is it this guy?
Well, it shows a little 13 ruby, no?
Oh, wait, you're right.
Oh, ow.
I wonder where's the big ruby?
No?
You just tried to catch him, I think.
No.
Oh!
Yeah.
Yeah!
What?
That's it?
You just took all of them!
I didn't even get a single one!
You went so fast you were like, let's get all of them!
And then you did it for yourself!
First you won't throw the ball.
Then you're mad, I throw the ball.
Because you didn't even let me try!
Make it make sense!
I boost, put her in the ball.
It's all mine.
Oh, wait.
I'm so sorry.
I legitimately genuinely thought there was about to be a big
boss and i was gonna let you catch the big ball no oh my god
that's kind of funny no i would would i'll give you a ton of
the base okay you'll get the best one no it's fine you want
it to catch him yourself huh yeah i want the satisfaction
you wish that were you huh mercy hit whoa
Ooh, I don't have these...
I don't have, like, a bunch of these guys.
Oh, these ones are cute.
It's a little VXE.
Yeah.
I think they're the legally distinct EVs.
Yeah, you can...
I can tell.
Oh, no, you got them.
Yeah, I have the mercy thing, so it doesn't kill them.
Yeah.
It's nice.
I'll kill them for you.
You want these guys, the Fox sparks?
Yeah, because they drop leather.
So I think you should always try to get them.
Okay.
That's what the mom was retelling me.
Wait, do you need leather?
I have two.
Here, I'll drop it.
I mean, I don't need them now, but in the base, we usually
end up needing leather stuff, and folks are saying you can
only...
Oh, oh, mint.
It's like red over there.
Yeah, it's pretty, right?
Yes, please.
Let's go.
I know.
Kind of reminds me of Autumn, and you know what happens to
Autumn?
Your birthday.
What is everybody going to be doing on October 1st?
They're going to be singing.
to me.
Yeah!
I hope so.
No, no, maybe they will.
Wait, this is my egg!
This is my egg!
My egg!
My baby.
Did you know what I mean?
Autumn rocks!
I got him.
Autumn rocks.
It's the best.
Is that the egg?
That's a monkey.
That's a monkey right now.
Oh my god.
Are you gonna get him?
Oh, you got him?
Oh, no.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I think, oh, you're gonna kill him.
You're gonna kill him.
No.
He's so cute.
He is pretty cute.
Fire monkey.
Fireball.
I don't think so.
Come, come, come, come.
come there's another one oh i'm trying to oh my power shot
oh my god are you talking what do you say i would love a
skill though like kind of automatically oh targets the guys
without me targeting them oh that's You just don't want to
play the game, I think.
I just have bad aim!
Let's go!
Yay!
Wait, I want another one too.
Oh, I have an inch.
Technical manual legendary.
Oh, shoot.
I missed again.
I missed.
That's so awkward.
So did he though.
trying to catch him oh did he how dare you how dare you
where do you go he's so fast my horse where'd she go she's
all the way up there oh oh Did you already claim like the
teleporter in this area?
Uh, yes.
Yeah, okay, I'm gonna go claim it.
The one by the, by the, wait, which one?
Wait, there's one like over here.
There's two, I think.
I don't know what you mean by over here.
This one, this one, this one.
The way where I'm going, there's a couple.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I got that one.
I got that one.
Okay, I'm going to claim it.
I will be back after the war.
Let's climb up because I guess I haven't gone.
Can I...
My horse, my horse...
I guess I can ride this guy.
Get on.
Oh, I have unused stat points.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna enhance my...
Part of me wants to do my attack.
Next tower plus boss.
Yeah!
We'll do my...
Actually, what did I just enhance?
I'm not quite sure.
That's okay.
We'll just go up.
Oh, I did make the grapple gun!
I did, I did, wait.
How do I equip?
Does it have to be under weapon?
What?
I'm wanted for assault.
What did you do?
I don't, I assaulted somebody.
Oh, there's the police right there.
There's literally the- I know, me, me, me, run, run, run.
I'm wanted for- What did you do?
I want my assault on somebody.
Also, oh my god, there's something flying.
Oh my god, I want that chicken.
Oh, what's that thing flying?
What's that thing flying?
Let's get it.
It's a flying chicken.
Get it.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
I'm wanted for assault.
What is, who did you assault?
I assaulted a guy.
And then, and then I assaulted like a cow.
And then, and then I didn't know he had a trainer and the
trainer wants me for assault.
Here, I'll let you catch him first.
A guy.
Oh, where'd he go?
Ow.
He's here, he's here, he's here.
Get him.
Mint, I violated the law.
I'm a criminal.
Yeah, I can tell.
Wait, my team is hungry.
Mama.
You never made a feedback, did you?
Oh, here we go.
No, I did.
I did make the feeding bag.
Also, this would be a phenomenal place for a second, baby.
Make sure it's hungry.
It would be, yeah.
How did they get hungry?
She just do be talking, don't she?
To who?
To where?
I'm over here.
She'd just be talking to anybody.
Oh, you put food into the feeding bag.
Oh, wow.
I had no clue.
All I did was make it.
Wait, this place is awesome.
I know, and there's a little alpaca for you to catch.
Yeah, I already got one.
Oh, nice.
There's a new thing here.
Desolate church.
I don't think we can activate it just yet.
It's not activating for me.
What?
Activate what?
The desolate church.
Oh, there's a...
Oh, cannot.
Come on, do while riding.
Yeah.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Yeah, yep, yep, yep.
Metal merchant.
Oh.
What kind of metal are they selling?
Hey, you, yeah.
That annoying cocky pal tamer from earlier, don't go acting
all high and mighty just because you beat me.
Yeah, yeah, I know you're strong, but now I'm kind of
curious to see what you really made of.
Catch a grisbolt and show it to me.
If you can do that, maybe I'll give you some credit.
They only show up in the number one wildlife sanctuary
pretty.
Oh, that's the island.
That's the island.
I went to Can I catch her very be tuber-coded try it You
might get them they might want me for assault.
Yeah, they might but you should do it anyway For the for the
vibes right like the girls who assault together.
You're right you're right criminals together There's no way
someone like you could catch one.
Oh my gosh It's very like Ricky tears-coded mama.
I'm in love
How's the grappling gun work?
Oh, now I'm a monkey.
The giant chicken is a flying mound, by the way.
Ooh, how early can we make the mountain?
Oh, I can talk to him.
I've had some good items in stock.
I want the hat!
Oh, all my medals are at home!
No, not her medals!
Go get him.
Teleport back home.
Yeah, I'm going.
I'm going to go get him.
Which hat?
Oh my God.
He's a good cat hat.
It's so cute.
We gotta go get my stuff.
He looks so cool.
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
He's selling hats.
And I want those hats.
I want those coins.
Where, though?
Okay, I have five on me.
But I collected, like, most of these.
I swear.
Oh, wait.
That's still mine.
Wait, where are they all?
Wait.
Where'd they all go?
Oh, here they are.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I collected, like, almost all of them.
these to be fair to be fair he also sells more accessory
slots for buffs huge huge huge um what was i doing let's put
some lettuce in here they can use that my frag grenade
needed for spear i'll just put that away
if you want to catch zoe you can attack her once without
aggroing then sphere
Get a new horse.
You're so right.
I gotta put my horse away.
My poor horse.
No, not the monkey.
Oh, were you eating?
Let's go back.
Oh, wait.
Where was it at, though?
Like, the desolate.
What is she doing?
Nightwing can fly.
Yeah, but I can't fly him.
I need a...
I don't have a saddle.
Do Zoe three out of four missions and you get her as a
reward.
Wait.
So people are just doing it.
People are just cat...
What is that?
Wait.
Oh my gosh, it's so cute.
It's so...
What are you?
I need that.
I need that cat.
Oh.
How did you... No, chill it!
No!
Chill it.
Chill it!
I've thought the mercy ring would work.
I like his song.
It's fun.
What do I want?
I want the lamb ball helm.
It's so cute.
Or the gloopy hat!
Mysterious box whose interior synchronizes with the owner's
body.
Yes.
And my hat.
Oh, Jelaya hat's so cute too.
Starfruit!
Okay.
Yay.
Yay!
Okay, let's put on my hat.
Oh, it's so cute!
Look at me, Zoe.
I look so cute, don't I?
Take whatever the heck that is.
Oh, here we go.
Nice.
Okay.
It's so goopy.
It is.
Wait, I want the meow.
I want the meow meow.
We need another meow meow.
Oh wait, he's gonna make me cold.
Yeah.
It's kind of spooky though.
Oh yeah.
Gloopy how it's so bouncy.
Yeah, so cute.
I'm so gloopy.
I wonder where my taro went.
Err.
I'm just looking around at the moment.
Hmm.
I need that cat.
Oh, there's a, there's a, it's like the other monkeys.
They have different elements too.
Oh, cat!
Question mark?
Maybe cat?
Not cat.
What are you?
A tombat!
I'll, I'll hold...
Foxparks is so strong though, you know.
Bat cat.
Hey.
Not nearly as cute, but still alright.
Oh, come back.
This sounds so mad.
Why are you so mad?
Yay!
I got a cat!
Dear.
No!
It's turning daytime!
I'm gonna miss out!
No!
Okay, so sad.
Four traits.
My cat is stacked, baby.
Night will come again.
Not soon enough, though.
That looks like a fast...
Teleporter.
I think this is where Matara was.
Wait, what's that up there?
That's fine.
Rip Wispa.
I know, he was so cute.
My little baby.
Matara's gone.
Oh, no, we're actually headed towards...
Oh, dogs.
Wait, aren't these guys like hostile?
Dang, they took him out one hit.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Did it work?
Mint, I caught a man.
I caught a man.
You got a man.
Wait, are you still on the run?
No.
Why did you kill all the other wolves that are catching
them?
I didn't mean to.
I don't know where they came from.
Oh, they're apparently fast.
Yeah, I caught a man.
He was like a little boss and I got him.
I got a little boss man.
Nice.
There's also a little teleporter here.
Did you get it?
No, not yet.
I just came to the area okay okay okay look did you see my
hat show me oh come come come come come we're gonna do this
oh my gosh stop that's so cute isn't it a little octopus i
know it looks so cute oh my god you're very like um taco
taco dachi coding right it's so cute is the what's it called
the um
Oh, I see it, I see it.
I know there's another teleporta the other way.
You what?
Oh, there's one right here too though.
Where's the man?
There was also more...
There were more wolves right there.
Didn't she want one?
What the heck are these?
Hang you?
They're so funny looking.
Oh.
Hey, don't block my thing.
Whoop, whoop.
Oh,
I'm trying to...
Oh, there we go.
We got them.
They can be gliders?
Wait, that's so cute.
Because their arms...
I want another one.
I'll get another.
Get the hangu.
Yeah, it's really cute.
I just got one too.
Come here, little guy.
Folks are asking who I'm playing with.
That's my girlfriend.
I'm playing with Matawa.
Yeah.
Oh, he's so cute.
Dude, I'm not going to lie.
Your sword looks...
Oh, there's another bandage now.
I pressed wrong button.
No!
No, come back.
No.
Yoink.
Hey!
You're not allowed to come out.
Yeah, we're on the sloppy sisters server, but we also...
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Oh, I was.
Here I come from the heaven.
Let's try to catch all these men.
Oh, yes!
actually really good at like doing work wait i can i think i
can get them down to one hp so we can catch them yeah yeah
let's do it they're so stupid yeah yeah wait i want to catch
one let me catch a man go go go catch your man get your oh
wait there we go i think you have one of your guys who's a
little oh do i is that possible no i'd maybe not wait
somebody just said i'm glad to finally catch you live i've
been enjoying being a first time home owner for the past six
months.
That's so exciting.
Now you just need a girlfriend or a wife or a husband.
What is that like?
You know?
Hope you and Mint have a wonderful time playing Palworld.
Love you both.
Okay, but if you had to pick one to shoot with a gun, who
would it be?
How many guys did I get?
Yehoo!
Good job.
Yeah, good job you.
Oh my God, look, look, look.
It's the same one you got.
Yeah.
Get him get him.
I want him.
I like that.
It's a sturdy valley strategy.
You know What is this?
Oh peep.
What is this thing?
They do join you.
Yeah, they do join you.
What?
These guys are so cute.
Oh, it's a flock.
It's a what?
It's a flock.
What did you tell me?
Exactly what you think.
Oh, it's a flock.
I need the flock.
I need the flock for a quest.
I I need him for a quest.
I give a flock.
I gotta give a flock.
What the hell?
I mean, what the flock?
Come on.
I need you, flock.
I need you.
Yes.
And these guys, they're so cute.
Oh, they're so cute.
Ami-oni?
I don't know.
Ami-ni-mi?
So cute.
I need them.
Oh my god.
I don't want to freak you out, but I just unlocked a
giga-sphere.
Gigasphere?
Oh, I'm out of spears.
I have like 100 if you come here.
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, you do?
Yeah.
I have none.
I have a hypersphere.
I just got level 20.
Whoa, I'm so close.
Ooh, and I got a weapon.
Okay, this is perfect.
I got a weapons bench so we can actually make our way
faster, I think.
And I don't know what to make that wooden board.
What the heck?
This game is so addictive.
It's so addictive.
Do you want to go to Ravine?
Or do you want to go try to capture it?
Oh, wait.
No, you have no more.
Right?
Um, well, I mean, I can just, I can just, uh, you know.
I have, wait, I have like green spears.
Let me drop some of my balls.
I wonder if I can drop...
L-ship.
Here.
I'm dropping 45 balls, beard.
You're dropping 45 balls?
Oh, wait.
I'm dropping 45 balls.
Whoa, thanks.
Wham.
Grab them here, grab them here, grab them here.
My arms are big because I'm massive and awesome.
That's why.
He is.
Yeah.
Do you want to go to the ravine or do you want to go fight
the There's a little guy a little big guy What's the little
guy?
I don't know.
It's a maybe it's like one of the little boss guys that I
see him like the guy the shadow guy I think it's baby
killer.
Look.
Yeah, it looks like a It's so cute.
Oops.
Oh, I didn't mean to use a hypersphere on it.
Oh, oopsie, oopsie.
I think I got it though.
Wait, so I just wasted it and I didn't even get him?
the hell i was throwing it i'm not helping you ever again no
please i'm sorry wait they're together look it's us it's us
at disney oh the amione's they're so cute arrogant pal
critic oh my god i know they're so sad
chest yeah fancy
oh I feel so bad oh they're crying they're crying you're a
monster you're a monster you got them too you're a monster
too I'll try wait was that mine or yours no I think that's
mine oh my god I'm not playing with you anymore no no no no
I'm so sorry apparently this wait wait wait min min min
there's some teeth apparently this woman has 20 lovers at
the same time and what's more she tells every single one of
them you're the only recently have lovers i've even formed
an organization who are you talking about timing victims
association are you talking about yourself the group to
divide her into 20 parts no i have many why maybe she's
scared of what they're planning but right now she's hiding
out under the cliff wait we can go kill a serial cheater of
a woman okay let's do it yeah there are like giving us the
intel wait this guy right here oh the bounties talk oh the
serial cheater she's right there wait the scam artist yeah
she has 20 what lovers at the same time can you imagine oh
my god i can't even imagine i can barely keep up with my
wife so what do they want us to do about it they maybe want
us to kill her are we killing her or we kill who are we
killing maybe or oh what if we kill the 20 we call them you
know i don't wait who are we also my inventory is full so
real talk do you want to go back to base for a little bit
craft some fresh go back to base i'm
just running around though wait but we gotta wait let's see
oh there's one down here There's one down here.
They want you to be numbers 21 and 22.
Everything!
Woolly Pop is so cute!
I must attack it.
Ow.
Oop.
There you go.
Hoop!
Oh.
Attack it.
Did I get it?
Did I get the other one?
Oh, I did.
Oh, I'm gonna eat this real quick.
Oh my god, it's a literal bomb.
Oh, and he died.
Oh my god, he killed himself.
Wait, maybe I can capture them when they're...
Oh my god, no, I can't.
Oh my god!
They're so violent!
Wait, let's see.
What else?
What can I get rid of?
I do want to go home.
Speed's remaining.
Permanently raises work speed.
Wait, I can use it on myself.
Ineffective when used by pals.
Goop, goop, goop, goop, baby.
What am I grabbing here?
some cotton candy cotton candy I can put food in my feed bag
oh that's right I do have it but I don't have any well I
have this food where's my feed bag
my feed bag my feed bag doco dish car feed bag under
accessories buy my feed oh this is it oh okay okay okay
interesting cool i learned wait can we eat cotton candy is
that consumable did these guys leave anything some oil no
they're so useless
consumable yes i don't know if i have to craft oh i see
another thing up there there's more of them more of them
Makes free cotton candy at the ranch.
I want to upgrade our base so bad so we can have every pal
doing something and working for us.
You know?
No, no, don't leave.
Don't leave.
Double them.
Yeah.
Whoop, whoop.
We'll get them.
Ouch, y'all.
uh need multiple bases is that really how that works oh yeah
we got an effigy wait there's a cave here where'd she go
she's home that's fine that's fine i'm i'm working i'm
making my way downtown going to the seal of arden
Cool sword.
Wait, I think it's over here.
I see it.
Very nice.
What are you?
Gold, gold, and more.
What do we spend the gold on?
I have so...
Where even do I see my gold?
Oh, I have points.
I forgot.
Um, let's do more stamina or multi-weight.
It becomes useful later, I believe you.
Oh, breeder.
Look at that full inventory.
Revolver.
Hey, you.
Yeah, you.
Gotta mean it.
Here's the deal.
I've decided to become a pal breeder.
That's right.
my very own pals.
Only problem is, I'm stuck at square one.
They say you need a cake to make the magic happen at a
breeding farm, but that kind of thing's not really in my
wheelhouse.
That's where you come in.
If you bring me five, wait, you actually need a cake.
If you bring me five cakes, I promise to make it worth your
while.
Trust me, I'm a man who keeps his word.
Wait, did they really need cakes?
Whoa, oh, Wait, I don't remember him.
There's this whole section here.
Five cakes.
Ah!
Oh.
You know you need five cakes to make a baby?
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Delicious, delicious baby.
I learned that today.
Yummy, yummy, delicious baby.
You don't eat the baby, you eat the cakes.
And then the babies happen because of it.
You know that they have...
babies and cakes in um in um new orleans oh yes the little
babies in the cakes yes yeah yeah yes i know yeah and
they're delicious i have so many training manuals but i
don't know who to use them on i'm picky just use them on
whoever just use them on any of the pals that you use okay
let's see also min that sword is crazy also look look look
at my name little girls i named them mimito they're working
so good look how fast they wow i hope they don't get an
oyster and die that would be awkward but yeah i sure hope
they don't you know it's a risk i'm willing to take you know
what i mean give it to the deer yeah i was gonna give it to
the deer
oh yeah they make everybody better let's go um we'll do fox
sparks oh i can't can i oh okay chill it maybe I need to see
if the hot milk makes them less insane.
Because if it does, then I think I found a solution to it.
Sanity one, not ream.
I never use Katava, but he does give me more.
Katava is cute.
He is cute.
I just never use him.
I always use that.
Do you ever find yourself using the same pals?
Yeah.
But like I kind of, I think I...
Oh my god, look!
No!
Wow, they're so cute!
carrying the milk sorry sorry my heart me minito together
they were like killing the milk from the big cow oh i didn't
see it oh my god you missed it i'm so sorry i want to see
the milk i do feel the milk oh i can show you milk i know
you can i don't want to see that though please spare me
please spare me hi matara and mint have been a fan of you
both for a long time but i used to Yeah.
Let's go.
Happy birthday.
This is the thing about us being hags is that, you know, to
many people being 40 is you're an older man.
To us, you're just a man.
Poor woman, you know.
Yeah, you're just a person.
You're just a person.
You're not even older.
You're just regular age.
Yeah.
This is just age, you know.
This is just age.
We're just old.
We're just aged.
Look, look, look, I have something for you.
I'm going to give you half, okay?
Okay.
it's gigaball whoa oh yeah wait how do you unlock it is it
under technology or yeah i'm level 20.
yeah me too but how do you unlock it yeah in tech in tech in
tech i think we need a ton of boards and the weapon where
are the bench yeah we need a ton of ingots so i think i'm
gonna teleport back if you remember there was an area with
like all the iron there and just go first i'm gonna feed two
of our little guys though because they're sick huh mega
glider yeah we can make so much stuff time for gun wait can
I get the gun where's the gun?
got it?
yeah I got the gun also we can make the flying saddle for
one of our birds oh duh and the weapons yeah no no my god
you need to where's the chart worker oh I can't I can't even
make it I won't even let me put it down this is literally
you two in that music video stop it's so cute You're like
gossiping and so...
No, we're being cute.
You're being cute.
You're no cute.
Look at that.
Oh, they liked my trick.
Watch this.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
They think I'm dancing for them.
Oh.
Weekend.
Can I not heal their weekend state?
40 couldn't be me.
Turn 39 yesterday.
Happy birthday!
Let's go!
Honestly, I really need y'all to understand.
getting older is and that's not old people propaganda it is
the truth all right all right i gotta go get some ingots so
i can make me too yeah if you remember where was that place
where we like had a bunch of it let me know when you tell i
don't remember i don't know this bite i'll find it good boy
good boy wait no there's some over here though i remember
wait there was some over here some here.
It's growing back.
Grab the ore.
Grab the ore, even if it exhausts you.
Wait, how much ore?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
We got 13 ore.
I want to make another weapon spot, you know?
How far does this reach?
Oh.
Just turned 31 six months ago.
It's a little belated, but...
Lucky is the Shine Files.
Oh, does that mean they're better?
Nothing personal.
Yeah, all my shinies that I've gotten.
Sometimes drop a flame organ when it's like...
What have we gotten?
Oh, look at all my men.
All your men, all your stinky little men.
Yeah, I got some stinky men.
Oh, I gotta go find that guy.
What the fuck?
Wait, where was he?
The fuck?
I think he, look up to one of the, like, most furthest away
things that you can find.
You'll probably find him.
Maybe.
I can't remember where the flocking man was.
Oh, my God.
This egg deer is so good at wood.
What the heck?
The what deer?
We got so much wood.
The egg deer.
What egg deer?
Look at all this wood.
Where?
The little guy, the deer.
getting all the wood where's all the wood i i it's in the
inventory oh he was like chopping all the wood up he's so
good at his job the one that's soaking in the hot tub right
now yeah he deserves it he's been working hard they're
extremely unhealthy due to neglect how are what are you
doing to them me your chill it spawn nothing oh wait there's
a bridge in that area is a bunch of iron ore oh wait he'll
not let me put these in here though i'm not a single thing
wrong also haven't done a single thing right that's that's
true that's real true are you dying no i'm just a little
flat it's a little a little flush room you know i'm gonna
put my okay my head's gear back on i feel naked death watch
this yeah oh wait sorry i wasn't watching where are you
Watch watch watch watch this watch this Where is she Hmm,
hello?
Hello in front of you.
Oh, I'm watching.
I'm watching.
I'm working.
Whoa Oh my god, you're so flyable.
You're so I know right?
You're so very cute You're so you're so cute.
She's so cute.
My heart can't handle it.
We are How it...
There.
Yeah.
Then I'm monkey.
You think we can take down that big guy down here?
Which one?
The one that's like level 40.
I think you should definitely try by yourself first, yeah.
Oh.
No.
I mean, like I could, but...
I think you should definitely try.
I don't think you...
I...
How much do I need for this?
Oh!
one more wait on the wooden boards wait electric bowls what
the heck this guy is crazy this daisy guy is crazy who's
daisy oh my god yeah he's got level three electric and like
too handy and too whatever he's gonna i do have the sword
now i'm so happy
all right time for me to go get all the iron Okay.
You used some!
Ah!
I'm sorry, I'll get more, I'll get more, I'll get more.
Nah, I'll get more, I'll get more.
I was literally...
I'm too sorry.
This is why I brought...
This is why I'm a lone wolf, everybody.
This is why I'm a lone wolf.
It's okay, there's some right here.
Oh, you produced seven!
wait unless she unless she's taking that too yeah you can't
trust anybody you can't trust them any you can't trust
anybody you can't trust them all you can't trust anybody you
can't trust them at all you can never trust anybody but
yourself I'm being way down too much yeah yeah I don't know
why she like I mean yeah we need lots of ore and stuff but i
mean i just got 60 by myself oh wait i'm carrying too many
items oh my stamina yeah you also need nails i know i know
she took everything oh guys look how slow i am wait you
think i can use this
oh we're we're going don't worry about it.
The grappling gun helps.
I gotta get closer.
Oh god.
Wait, wait, wait.
Why can't I grapple to trees?
It was added to my favorite pals.
Shoot the ground?
Oh wait, you can actually do that?
Oh, okay.
That was scared.
Oh.
Why only saw... Oh, is there like a...
Oh, there is a cooldown.
I just saw it.
Okay.
Two.
One.
Okay.
We're gonna make it over to there.
Seven.
Six.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
What if you drop some of your stone?
No, that's weak sauce.
That's weak sauce.
We gotta think big.
dropping my stuff that's admitting defeat oh wait can I not
go up this it's fine it'll lift me it'll lift me
or my grappling gun will yeah never drop things always max
items exactly exactly and then you pixel perfect they'll
grapple All right, we're almost there.
Wait, but we're asleep.
Okay.
Yeah.
They're not working on it because they're asleep.
No!
I think I only needed, like, this many.
The mega grapple.
I know.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Okay, a couple more.
A couple more nails.
We got this.
Oh, yeah, I can just get my own fox.
You're so right.
Work.
Where are you going?
No, don't cook.
Work for me.
Work for me!
No!
I don't want you to cook.
He's cooking.
Palmo is super fun.
Hello, Minto.
Hi.
I brought more iron.
I'm going to try to find a better stop for us.
that's better stuff what's stuff better stuff so if we level
up our base we're gonna be able to make another base and if
you remember there was like a whole ring of iron so then we
could like automatically get iron my guy oh refining yes yes
do do do yes wait why does he listen to you and not to me oh
you can set him so if you go here and you can look at the
task i kind of auto ha ha ha ha so that way it's easier for
us i automated some of the tasks for us oh yeah i just need
I just need I just need Three ingots Wait, where'd my nails
go?
Wait, did I not grab them?
Oh, I just grabbed them, but I'm putting them in the
inventory Oh my god You're in the chest, they're in the
chest Stop!
I'm literally I'm literally putting them in the chest for
everybody Do you?
I'm making Okay, hold on You, I'm being a good girl No I'm
being a good boy Okay, I just need two Ingots, don't Don't
touch them.
No, no, no.
They're in the base.
You can have them.
No, no.
He has to make them.
Oh, I see.
We're not pals anymore, guys.
We're, we're, we're, we're anti-pals.
Okay, grab it.
Okay.
Yes.
I want a gun.
Okay.
We're in.
anti-pals.
Yes, keep pounding.
Keep pounding away.
Yes.
I need 50 ingot.
Wait, the high quality pow oil.
We get those from those dang parrots.
Very nice.
Uncommon crossbow.
Not to be mistaken for the common crossbow.
They look the same.
We could do poison arrows.
Those blasted pirates.
You have done well.
Young fox sparks.
With huggy fire.
Wait, where'd Matorra go?
Where'd she go?
Oh.
I wish if you caught them on fire, they automatically cook
their food.
You know?
Oh, it's decreasing though, I can only hold him for so long.
Where'd she go?
Oh, there she is.
Wait, she's going to the islands.
I want to go.
Thank you, bye.
He's so cute, isn't he?
special fish I need a good fishing rod though are we headed
towards her oh yeah she's on this island wait what's the
green one is it like even specialer is he even better chill
it you've been good I'm letting you read chill it you're I'm
teaching you how to read.
That you see?
Teaching you how to read.
Alright.
How's mine?
How are they looking?
Yeah, they're looking good.
They're looking good.
Shiny ones on land.
Oh, okay.
I hear her singing.
There she is.
Hello?
Hi.
Are you following me?
I was.
You missed me.
Do you want to go to the island?
It's over here.
Oh, wait.
Where?
This way.
Is it like golden island?
This one with like the big sphere around it over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Okay, watch out.
You might explode.
Okay.
What is this guy?
There's a treasure.
Wait, there's a guy here.
Newbie pal tamer.
Yeah, that's you.
It's true though.
I am a newbie.
Don't be mean to newbie.
oh my god wait he's he looks like he's like 50 years old oh
my god he died he's got that little like yeah yeah yeah you
must be a pal tamer you heading for the wildlife sanctuary
see that gigantic dome that's a relic from a lost
civilization built for the purpose of observing how pals
evolve in an extreme conditions or so the story goes either
way the little the smart thing to do is to steer clear i
went going myself ones but it was crawling with pals that
were on an entirely different level from the ones here.
There was some sort of machine?
Keeping a low altitude patrol of the island.
Oh, there really is.
Oh, yeah.
It'll one shot kill you.
Really?
And that's when you want to go on the island?
Yeah.
Let's go.
I'm ready.
I made it before.
And then she died.
I hope I don't die.
Me neither.
every cat is being activated right now.
Yeah.
Um, Kampura.
Play.
Oh, oh, wait.
I'm going to drown.
Oh.
No drowning allowed.
No drowning.
There is a way to get inside.
Mm-hmm.
We are currently on the way inside.
Yeah, but like an easier way.
Avoid the red light.
Okay.
We can do that.
easy peasy yeah we're like the metal gear you know it's just
like infiltrating it's literally the same it's foxhound all
over again it's true i activated your cat mission
accomplished what is the alexa stream fire on by thensetsu
.exe that's not what it's called i had to take a shot i had
to take it i had to do my boat oh shoot what did i just do
oh it's level 28 minto oh i i beat some of the things in
here and caught them already damn okay yeah oh dang though
what is that actually oh oh what about it yeah come on
health appear i need you to be attacking that little guy Oh,
it's burn on?
I thought it was fire on.
Wait, what's that sound?
Why is there... Why is there... Wait.
Don't worry about it.
Um, do you hear that?
I think it's me attacking the Lunar.
Maybe, yeah.
I think it's upset at you.
Well, I'm gonna summon a little guy.
Okay, we'll get it.
Oh, you got a little guy!
He's shooting!
Wait, why is she so sexy, though?
Very pretty.
We definitely gotta try to edit her.
Oh, it's my pal attacking.
Is he even out here?
Oh.
There you go.
Oh, my gosh.
No, 28.
I want her.
Yeah, I want her.
Go, go, go!
Oh!
I wonder.
Where'd she go?
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Did you catch her?
No, you killed her!
I didn't know!
You killed her!
No!
How could you do?
It's okay, let's keep seeing if there's another one.
Wait, is this what I think it is?
Wait.
Oh, no.
Let's keep exploring.
Let's find another one.
Wait, was that the special thing?
No, it's not even the special pal in here.
There's another one.
Oh, this guy, he leaves you alone.
Really?
Well, no, we're gonna kill him.
Oh.
Uggy.
Holy.
Wait, what?
Oh, my palace was knocked out.
We can see what he did.
Oh, wait, you know, okay, I wonder if I can get him.
I think you got a type advantage on her chillin, that's why.
No, it's okay.
You're wasting the balls, I got you.
Yeah, but they're your balls, so it doesn't matter.
I gave them to you, they're your balls now.
Where'd he go?
Oh, you got him.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Fifty-eight percent.
Sixty-two!
Bunch.
Me too.
Let's hit him a little bit more.
Oh.
58?
I don't think so.
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
Oh,
my noodle.
Oh, my noodle also died.
That's okay.
It's okay.
We got more.
You call him that noodle?
That's weird.
Yeah, my noodle died.
Okay.
Mine is back alive.
Okay, mine is back alive.
Wait, how am I supposed to get home?
No, I think it regenerates in your inventory.
Um, how am I supposed to get home?
I'm stranded.
Yeah, I'm stranded in here.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, actually, how do I get home?
You'll be fine.
It'll regenerate back.
You'll see.
They don't!
Not in your inventory.
No!
Mine was dead and it regenerated.
Alright, wait.
Yep.
Don't do it anymore.
Oh!
My dear, my dear is about to die.
Get him, get him.
47?
Oh, dang.
That was not great.
Oh my god, why am I taking damage?
Why is he aggroing on me?
I gotta get out of here.
Okay, good luck with the island.
I love you.
Bye, Vicky.
Bye, bye.
Let's go!
I have no friends to ride.
Oh, man.
I only have this thing.
Yeah, I know I'm taking strays.
I wasn't even attacking him.
I wasn't trying to do anything.
Is this a flower?
Beautiful flower.
Where can I go to get out of here?
Wait.
I actually am stuck, you guys.
Oh.
Can you flamethrower or Mata?
Unfortunately, Matara was too afraid of PvP.
So she asked for it to be turned off.
Can you grapple your way out?
I'm actually not sure.
I don't think I can.
Can you grapple the water?
That's not what I'm trying to do.
Come on, please.
There we go.
Alright, we're here, we're here.
Oh my gosh, the cooldown on this thing is way too long.
How am I supposed to live my... Wait, no, no, no.
How am I supposed to think I'm Spider-Man?
You know?
Yep, please, please.
I need to stop it.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
Can I grapple the water?
Dang.
We just have to go this way, folks.
We'll make it.
Swim then mount.
Yeah, I don't have anything to mount, buddy.
Both of them are dead.
Why do you think I left?
Oh, I think actually we'll make it.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I do see one over here.
Fast travel.
It's just a little far.
Grapple.
It's so inefficient.
At its current form.
I'm grappling.
Okay.
Cancel grapple midway.
Wait, can you do that?
I must wait.
Oh, oh.
Ha!
Come on!
It said left control, but I definitely didn't press that.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, come on.
The grapple is...
I thought it was OP.
Maybe once it's a little more...
It's up here, no?
The...
The thing I'm trying to get to, it's up here, no?
Wait.
Ooh, there's treasure...
Wait, did I see the treasure chest?
No, there's no way.
What did I see?
What's that?
Who's that big guy up there?
Oh, it's right here.
I was right.
This is a fast travel, right?
Please sit...
Uh oh.
Marine Echo Bone.
It's not a fast travel.
There's nothing around here.
It's a key item, but it's a late game item.
Well, I guess I'll just save it for now.
Oh.
Let me...
Please.
Okay.
are you standing on bones it looked like it yeah i think so
yep all right watch this we're gonna talk to this guy who
are you oh my god i thought it was a cat from far away are
you looking for a dungeon tool i guess we've got the same
adventurous streak i climbed all the way up here to find one
but no luck so far so i'm taking a breather speaking of
dungeons have you heard of a tombat That pal can actually
sniff out the location of dungeons.
If you trade me one, I'll give you one of my fa- I ate some
milk.
Some items in return.
Wait, don't I have one?
Oh, I do!
He's kind of good, though.
I accidentally needed a spear and caught her accidentally.
Oh, my cat.
Combat is goat, don't give.
I can just, yeah, I catch more.
Oh, I don't think I'll come back here.
With this little one, I won't get lost on the way to any
dungeon.
Once I add a bit more rest, I'm heading out to explore.
Okay.
Oh, I got a pelt armor schematic and a mega, oh, five
megaspheres.
Okay, thanks.
the human if i catch the human do i get their tombat oh
shoot no so lame whoa what are you a rocky egg oh my oh my
god we found one a fast travel actually i think that's the
one that's like close to home
I don't know if we'll make it.
Oh, hello?
Come on, Kelly.
Hi, Mint.
I have some tips.
Oh, do you need help?
All my things are dead.
I can't go.
No.
Do you want me to come help you grab your things?
What do you mean, grab my things?
You said all my things are dead.
Yeah, my pals are dead, so I can't ride them.
I'm slow.
back i think we should grab a fire pal because the reason
did you just open that in front of me as i was going on my
way to get it no can
you say you love me back
my girlfriend's back this is why i play on the server by
myself you guys oh my god i was on my way to get that She
was standing there for like five seconds before I literally
reach it and then she opens it in front of me!
Ruby, I have decided that you are in.
I have decided that you are my guy.
I have decided, Ruby, that you are my guy.
And then because of that, you Elgrove, wait a second.
Hi, welcome back.
Don't talk to me.
Me, Engie.
Hold on.
I'm going to bring him in my...
Wait.
Wait a second.
I leveled up the wrong deer.
No.
Oh, dear.
Oh, wait.
This guy's better.
Never mind.
It's fine.
I should bring elk egg to deer against right um against what
so there's an electric guy level 30 and i think if we both
brought like a good pokemon we could beat them oh the one
that's the uh the jolt deer whatever yeah yeah univolt yeah
yeah yeah i'm the old guy yeah i should probably explore
this area I also got a ruby.
Would a ruby or a...
That's not bad.
Park be better.
What do you guys think?
Now.
Probably tiny spark.
Probably ruby.
We can take this guy for now.
Wait, can I make this sad on that?
Make it.
Ground pile drop 40%.
Oh, is it 21?
Oh, it's 21.
Okay, we're so close.
Purification.
Oh my god.
Lindo, I've gotten so many cool stuff.
Yeah.
For us.
Look, look, I got a violet.
Did you see that?
No, I didn't.
Let me see.
What did you see?
Good luck.
Uh oh.
Oh!
Done, done, done, done.
Yeah, we need that gun.
Too bad PvP is off because she knew, she knew that she would
be dead a thousand times.
She would be dead a million times.
All right, for now, I want to, like, catch some things and
level up so we can, uh...
Oh, wait, that's my grappling gun.
This guy is so fast, but I know we can do this.
He's only level 12.
Oh.
Pock Sparks, you're too strong.
You're too strong, my little friend.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, yeah.
Is that a shiny?
There's a shiny!
No, I want to get to level 21.
Let's get shiny.
Another one bites the dust.
Wait, so if I mount him, right?
If I do this, he won't kill them, right?
Because of my mercy ring.
Ouch.
No, calm back, calm back.
Oh, yo.
No!
Ow!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
Help!
Get him out of here!
Kill that guy!
It's okay.
We can have one as a sacrifice.
Yeah!
Alright.
We just took out the extra hands that were...
Oh.
Are they mad at me?
Are you mad at me?
Wait, I think that guy's mad at me.
Wait, are you mad at me?
No, you're not mad at me.
Eat the raw meat.
That was close, wasn't it?
I'll put up my... I'll give my health.
Honestly, I could use more health.
Oh, I can't do this.
No!
I'm not a pal.
Raw meat.
Yeah, they're fighting each other.
Oh, wait.
Now, though, I can do the technology for this.
And now...
We can just go... Oh, tomato!
A musket.
I'm eating, I'm eating.
Let's catch some more cows.
Yeah.
They're stupid, they don't know anything.
What the?
Get in my ball!
Ouch!
Close.
Uh-oh.
He is mad.
How did you know?
Here.
Do some work.
Oh.
Well.
He always one-shots him.
No.
I wonder if I can take this guy.
2 OP.
Wait.
Come here.
come here
oh still oops oopsie wait oopsie no way still
it's awkward oh my god the girls are fighting why do they
fight each other they're so silly um where's a fast travel
over here yeah fire burn damage
we keep fighting another day
I guess one thing I do want to do is to search for clues
about the next tower I guess we could just go huh we can
just keep doing the tutorial I gotta find that that guy that
wanted the duck though the the the fog king the visitor has
left the base what does that mean oh the guy that you have
to pay i sure hope she didn't pay
it was me i wanted the dog meaty cloth welcome back mint i
had suddenly paid the raiders and now they're not attending
us i feel so bad i didn't do it on purpose what why did you
pay I was like the negotiator and then I just started
clicking buttons wait what happened to the bat why is he
dead which bat oh um he I he got killed when he was um what
is it called he got killed when I was exploring oh wait
where is he I took him out I took him out because he was Oh,
can you, yeah, can you put him back?
No, because he was dead.
But after he's revived, he has four handlings, so he's going
to be bringing...
Look, look, I got a flower.
She's so pretty.
A flower.
Did you place it?
Yeah, she's in the, she's in one of the things, doing the
stuff.
Yeah, I know he's in my storage now because Matara killed
him.
It does not deserve him.
It's true, you can have him for a little bit.
You can have him.
I give you permission.
Yeah.
I am going to go get us more iron because I need to make
that cool sword that you got.
I need it.
It's so good, actually.
Mm-hmm.
I'm jealous.
I need it.
Uh-huh.
It's stats rose.
Let me see how much I need for this sword.
How much I need for this sword.
I'm giving this guy...
me 52 ingots?
Yeah, it's a lot of ingots.
I worked hard for it.
Yeah, you did.
Oh, my God.
The crossbow.
Ooh.
I heard it's not so good, though.
Really?
Yeah.
Why?
They said something about it.
Egg Deer Thera saddle?
Where did you get?
I got it.
Yeah, you unlock it in the technology tree.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I'm going to make one too.
Yeah.
Well, you can do bear traps.
Now we can to swap them.
Wait, wait.
Makes the sphere heavier, reducing its range, but increasing
its capture power.
Wait a second.
Can I not?
Can I not work this unless I have a pal working at them?
Cooking, oh, the cooking pot.
We need that.
We need the cooking pot.
Yeah, we do.
It's going to be fast.
We need everything.
I'm going to go back together.
We need it though to upgrade our base.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
Is it under food?
Oh, wooden board.
Oh, we can do that.
We can do that easy.
easy easy easy easy wooden board what was it three wooden
board yeah I'm gonna make the musket do it oh wait small
girl big musket oh yeah oh yes we'll put this next to all
the other foods.
That means I got to pee again.
Can I put that in?
Nope.
Wait, wait.
Don't pee.
Come back and help me build.
Okay.
Build while you pee.
Here, bye.
Bye.
Now I'm going to make a busket.
Now a busket.
I'm gonna make it.
Wait.
We need a mill.
Oh no.
You heard wrong.
Wait, actually, how much do I need for the musket?
Oh, here it is.
I have 18.
Wait, I have enough oil, though.
That's sick.
Let's go.
Wait.
He's refining.
Yes, acquire.
My basket.
I need one more.
Just one more.
Alright, little guy.
Goink.
Please make a basket.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Oh, this is going to take a minute.
This is a bucket.
No, I said it wrong.
I said it, bro.
Musk gets really slow.
Yeah, but look how cool it looks.
Stop judging my choices.
If I want a gun, I can have a gun.
Actually, let's summon this guy.
Wait, cancel.
Oh, not cancel.
E.
All right, working.
I'm working.
Yes.
It's hard for that one shot.
though.
I'll let one shot.
Who gave Mint a gun?
Me!
I love it.
Tall girl, big gun.
My gun!
Do a crime.
I have been.
I've been stealing people.
Good, good, good, good, good, good.
That's what I like to see.
Yes.
Yeah, yes, yes.
Check out my gun.
Show me, show me, I want to see you use it after.
Oh, wait, that actually looks so cool.
I don't even know.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Don't get me, don't get me.
Oh, don't, oh, no, no, no, no.
Wait, what ammo does it use?
It uses musket ammo.
Oh, dummy.
Wow.
Can't believe she doesn't know that.
It uses musket ammo.
Wait, actually, what ammo does it use?
Course ammo.
Okay.
I think we're, there's some of that somewhere around here.
We can probably make the ammo soon as well.
uh i had some course like course light or uh no heavier
heavier heavy course i see it yeah yeah i only have the
course light not my favorite beer but yeah lots of course
okay cool okay wait the weapon workbench is better how does
it work does it just allow us to make things like i think it
oh whoops i didn't mean to grab that i think it just um
and she's wet.
Oh, faster.
Then I'm going to disassemble some of our, like, slightly
older stuff just so we can have...
No, no, no, some of them you still need.
Yeah, yeah, no.
I'm not disassembling everything.
Oh, but you did disassemble it.
I'm just keeping some stuff.
Don't worry about it.
I'm keeping some stuff.
But the one that you need, you disassembled.
Wait, which one did I need?
That I disassembled?
Yeah, you the one that we need.
Oh, wait, which one?
Oh, that's for me to know for you to find out.
No.
Can you just tell me?
So wait, we have the weapon.
So you say the crossbow no good?
I don't know.
That's what people told me.
It could be fine.
I'm going to try the crossbow.
Why does the ore go back in there?
That's so weird.
Okay, I'm going to...
Oh, I see.
I actually did eat all the benches away.
Yeah, you did.
You did.
i did i did yeah i did high quality work but wait we only
need wait we only need one more in god and then i'm gonna go
get way more in yeah grab it yo we got a high quality work
wow oh wait huh where's my where's my stuff all right minto
pinto let's go where are you going i'm baking the high
quality workbench.
Whoa!
Oh, my god.
Why you giggling?
Nothing, I wasn't nothing.
I want to go see your gun!
I want to...
Crime.
Oh, wee.
My gun?
What about it?
Yeah, I want to go see it.
I want to go see your gun.
Ha!
I have it.
I have it in my hands.
Yeah, but I want to see you, like, shoot it, you know.
I want to see you go, bang!
There is a...
There is a guy.
Wait, wait, the goblin's turf.
I think it's kind of hard.
Have you been over?
there no there's also a level 30 guy we can try wait the
level wait the unival we can try the unival oh wait i didn't
get the fast travel over there though um wait fast travel
where wait to the unival which which we are we thinking of
the same guy hold on look at the grisbolt is the one i'm
thinking oh i don't even see the grisbolt where's the
grisbolt he was in the
him oh ducks just suck okay well i'm gonna go bye no no show
me where it is
there's a guy right here that i want to see grisbolt's in
the sanctuary yeah yeah i figured that's what she saw um but
we want to go south a little bit and find oh oh this is the
breeder oh this is the okay this is here this is here
No, I think...
Oh.
They're being...
They're being a little naughty.
They're being naughty.
Wait, are these arrows?
Nice.
What's this one?
What is this?
Oh, we can totally do this!
We can totally do this!
Reminder that Doki didn't disable PvP.
Yes, she did.
You are wrong.
Whoa!
Um...
Too bad I don't have my...
I guess we'll go fox sparks again.
Or...
Or ground.
Maybe ground is a fire.
Oh, did I... I'm out of eva.
Did I hit him?
Oh, we're so slow.
This is so awesome.
I want to call my dear.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Ah, wait, wait, wait.
There we go.
Sometimes I mix up E and Q.
Anybody else?
Everybody be doing that.
Obtained five PAL bounty tokens.
Oh.
Yahoo!
All the time.
I know, I'm like, I'm like, you just end up throwing
everything, right?
That was pretty easy.
You can ride this, but it's going to overheat you.
I can take it.
So we got him.
I feel like we should explore this area, but maybe I should
go home and grab it.
grab my
my chillit and stuff right but now I can at least ride this
guy
we're not so desperate for legs careful where you point your
basket you'll freak someone's plungus out I'm so I'm telling
you guys my brain has been so overworked lately I don't
everything it feels like a mush.
Take hand off keyboard to scratch nose.
Accidentally throw the high quality sphere at nothing when
you... I know, it's the worst.
It's the worst.
I'm sure you can rebind things.
Is it, by the way, until the stuff spawned back?
Hello, Minko.
I'm grabbing stuff for ice.
I'm grabbing all the iron.
I make all the things.
Iron, iron.
I got a new guy.
He's kind of cool looking.
Yeah.
Check him out.
Wait, he might actually...
What does he do, actually?
Oh, he's going to do wood.
Ooh.
Oh, wait, he's a fire guy?
Yeah, but he's not working the fire.
Girl, oh, go into the little...
Here, here, I'll show you.
Yeah, I don't know how.
You see the little podium right here?
This?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, go into C.
Oh, no, sorry, not C.
Go into V.
V?
And then look at him.
Where is he?
Did you set him?
R?
Oh, we can put him on fire, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Perfect.
Is he level two?
Oh, he's level three.
I'm getting a huge dragoon out of there.
That's insane, Mint.
Yeah.
Where did you get him?
He was in a dungeon.
You're so cool.
This is the one that I wanted to go see.
Oh, but he's not doing the iron.
He's doing a...
He's going to do it when he's done with the cooking.
That's all I can.
Okay.
I'm taking some meal.
Actually, yeah.
Oh, my God.
walk is so some milk some milk i wish you could add more
things while they're already working on it you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah i what would you add if it would chuck could
chuck wood i'm the milk i got some milk who is this beauty
the the butterfly wow i know isn't she the cutest so cute i
am gonna keep one of the fox bark thing because he's an
artisan so he's like 50% faster on all the stove on the
stove and then mint I got some bad news for what I'm about
to do okay what because you're not gonna like it what are
you you're not sit you're you're staying alive I'm going to
kill them kill who oh don't worry about it who are you
killing don't worry about it who are you killing
Wait, are you eating?
Are you eating the pals?
Wait, who are you killing them?
I'm trying to kill the pals, but I don't know how to kill
them.
Oh my god, you're gonna eat them alive.
Yeah, I'm gonna eat them.
I'm gonna skin them.
I'm gonna make... Oh, we need it.
Oh, press R.
Butcher.
Oh!
Mint, don't look!
It was censored!
Mint, don't look.
don't look don't look oh my god it's for us we need to eat
we need to eat we are hungry girls okay don't look why are
you butchering them for meat for leather for free morgans we
need it don't worry about oh i didn't mean to sleep sorry
wait can i do that to the humans try it grab make a cleaver
and then yeah where do you make the cleaver under is it wait
in the in the weapons i didn't mean not okay under weapons
wait what did i just acquire oh i got your crossbow sorry oh
it's fine can you put it in the thingy i want my quiet home
hold on
oh they're hungry so you need to like do it fast oh your
crossbow oh my quiet bone there it is um what was i doing oh
the cleaver wait oh oh wait oh no the violet is minus 50
work speed oh man why because he's a muscle head she's got
attack plus 30 percent oh it's kind of funny um okay cleaver
yeah and now now i put them in my party yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then how do i drop them you like put them in the in the
middle like you put e so that they get summoned oh my god
okay your guy is making so many ingots you're welcome he's
awesome oh he's running he's running he's running get him
just press 4 and then just do put 4 oh yeah wait do what
which one oh butcher oh ha
You killed it!
Why would you do that?
Mint, you murderer.
Wait, did I get his meat?
Oh, wait.
I thought you got meat.
That is why I was murdering them, but I think...
I thought you were supposed to.
Me too.
I think I was just murdering them.
Maybe you auto-eat it.
Maybe.
No, I don't think so, because you would be able to build the
meat and...
Hmm.
Alright, um...
Yeah.
Minto, quick question.
Oh, I got ammo.
Cool.
Put my stuff.
What?
Where did you put my stuff?
You had one of my little fiends.
You had grabbed one of my little fiends.
Oh, yeah.
You should find it.
Okay.
Hide and seek.
I'll probably make...
I'll probably make bigger things in a little bit.
We're gonna go explore this area, guys.
Bye-bye!
Bye!
Have fun, Pookie!
I'm sick of seeing this big old area on my map.
There's gotta be a fast travel in there nice boat yeah we're
gonna go we're gonna go we're gonna go all right come on
we're gonna go explore this area finally it's been bugging
me no way yes way all your dreams are coming true today as
we ride into the sunset set of exploration
maybe I do need oh oh yes yes yes yes nice wait okay jump up
and jump up again and keep doing it oh yes yes yes oh no oh
no no no no no no oh no We're fine.
I didn't want to get too far off trail.
We just got a little bit far off.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Yes.
Where are we?
Oh, wait.
I don't think I've reached it yet.
The air has double jump.
Oh, thank you for reminding me.
That's not me being sarcastic, by the way.
That's a legitimate thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Oh,
come on, let's go.
He sounds like an eagle sometimes, like a hawk.
Oh, cute.
Wait, I see a hedgehog.
I see candy corn over there.
Okay.
All right, keep going in.
Keep going in.
I want to get to that question mark because I definitely
think it's something we could probably handle.
You know?
Oh, look how cute they are!
Yes!
So cute!
Yeah, never saw a cat- No,
you're fine!
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I can get him.
100%?
You did not watch your friend get stolen by me.
the way actually since there's so many of these guys here i
feel like we should just grab oh what's going on in here
joel talk wait up small settlement wait hold on come on
let's get all the other guys up here we got to level 22
let's go and then uh cannon oh
It was so slow and he had it.
Yahoo!
Alright.
We just need...
How many more?
Holy cow!
Just grab them.
Yes.
No, no, no,
no.
Yeah.
4 out of 5.
Oh, oops.
No, and my hip finger slipped.
Legitimately.
Yeah.
They fear you.
They should.
They know they're about to get caught.
Yeah.
We're getting their organs or something somehow.
Let's see.
Let's do my...
Let's do attack a little bit more Because I've been using my
sword quite a bit As long as you see the white sphere next
to their name That means you still have to catch some Yellow
sphere means you got to five Is there any Is there any
reason why I should go past five?
Let's head a bit north I say that as I go the opposite
direction But I'm just vantage point Oh, okay.
Sell excess pals.
We're selling the excess!
I said I was going to go north and then I changed my mind
entirely.
I'm following the path now.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Ooh.
I really thought there would be a fast travel point here.
There's something over here, though.
You make their pal effect better.
Don't forget the waypoint.
Wait, where is it?
That's what I'm looking for.
There's that down there.
I feel like I've been there, though.
Oh, it was in the village!
Now don't hurt you.
It was?
Oh, I see.
Oh, it blended in the...
Okay, thank you guys.
It blended in with the rocks on the map.
I don't even see it.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't run into my...
Minto ate hot milk.
Yeah, I did.
Straight from the source.
I was wondering why you turned around.
I was looking for it on the map, I didn't see it, and I
thought...
You know, I thought.
Oh yeah, we thought.
Nice jump.
Oh, oh my gosh, it really was right here.
It does blend in with the autumn theme.
Just a bit, right?
Ooh.
Oh my gosh, they just let that chicken on the table.
That's crazy.
What's going on in here?
Wow.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
We can come back now that we can fast travel here.
Get off the mount?
No, it's okay.
We're not gonna stay.
I did want to head.
Oh, heading towards this way oh there's shops and stuff nice
okay we'll come back we'll come back why do they eat so loud
in this game you know all those like fears to fathoms games
I love making fun of them with my friends will like hear
someone do a loud crunch or something and I'll be like oh
that's a fears to fathom noise oh that's a fears to fathom
moment and it makes me think of that it's like they were
trying to have like a minecraft munching moment but it's
just there's something wrong about it I don't know what it
is Minecraft munching sound is so like pleasant to listen to
but this one oh was this guy a batty
oh shoot shoot uh eat?
Stone blast?
Oh!
Uh...
Ouch, uh, this mount?
Wait, come on, get off.
Let me get off.
Can I get off now?
Can I please, can you please get off?
Can I get off the mount?
Can I please get off the mount?
I want to capture him?
Get off the mount?
Can you get off the mount?
Thank you!
No!
Whoa!
It's like a whole...
It's a whole guy!
Area!
You can throw from the mount.
I know, but I didn't want to.
I didn't want to.
Alright, fox sparks.
We don't need to capture guys.
Who is he shooting at?
Oh, they're shooting at the spark hit.
Oh, I don't want to be in the crossfire.
Mercy hit.
No, just kidding.
Lull, never mind.
Who are you?
A little pal.
Thank you.
Did we get all their stuff?
Not yet.
The most not Pikachu I've ever seen.
ever.
Um.
Okay, we're just going to keep on...
Oh, there's another one.
Okay.
Perfect.
You really do have to hold it for so long.
I thought that changing the settings, you know how when I
changed it so that...
You don't have to long press or whatever?
I thought that would fix it.
But it did not.
I guess that's why I got confused.
Oh, berries!
Look at that.
That looks yummy.
Oh, poison blast.
Maybe don't eat those.
Maybe.
Maybe the name is a warning.
Not for mounts.
I have learned.
It's Team Ukachui, guys.
Whoa.
Gosh, the maps in this is so awesome, don't know?
Press E and hold F to summon and enter.
to ride it.
Wait, that's...
Hello!
Wait, I can take him.
Um, I can, right?
Oh my gosh.
Uh, I don't like fighting with them, but...
Oh my gosh, I forgot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
We're doing poorly.
We're doing... I'm not hitting a single bit.
see oh this is so bad
huggy fire where did that guy come from uh my mercy no my
wait no my mercy hit wait I thought the huggy would do it oh
whatever I didn't get a single one that sucks no my Oh, the
burn damage!
I lost my guy.
The burn damage.
What the?
Sorry, he scared the heck out of me.
Wait, wait.
Oh, no, oh, oh.
He just, he just, he just pushed him over.
Wait, they keep respawning though, it's fine.
Okay, maybe, maybe.
They respawn quickly here for some reason.
Oh, we got him!
We got him!
Incentoram!
Oh, can I have your Pokemon?
I mean, sorry, your pal?
Mercy hit?
But not from him.
Wait, we need this guy to... We need him to respawn.
Okay, take you back.
Okay, respawn.
Come back to life.
I'm guessing.
Okay, take out your guy, please.
Release him?
Oh, there he is.
These, these punks?
Ouch.
Okay, now I'll send him out.
Now you can kill him.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's get out of here, maybe?
Oh, no, I gotta find the waypoint.
Oh.
Alright.
We got what we wanted.
we can leave now oh man oh oh no uh can i actually get out
of here wait oh shoot oh shoot wait i'm trapped no we're not
yes we are no we're not yes we are we're fine where was it
maybe this way just follow the road you can always climb
yeah but i have to on my it's fine we're fine I was gonna
say that I don't think they're following us but that lasted
whole gem that lasted quite a long time that epic music
who's in here wait a person oh you're a pal tamer aren't you
it's about time lady luck started smiling on me would you
mind helping the fellow out and get me out of this cage here
no so that's how it is nah no harm no foul don't you worry
I've got myself out of worse scrapes than this and I'll do
it again too yeah oh oh I'm cold I'm cold oh I didn't mean
to do that oh oh who are we attacking now come back where is
okay Is it in Cineram?
Whoa, cool!
Whoa, it's so cinematic.
Wow!
Area map unlocked.
Oh, nice!
It's just this area right here.
We do need this sea breeze archipelago church.
Wow.
Those mountains you can climb?
Oh my gosh, wait, you can.
How am I out of ammo?
Is there not like a reload button?
This is out of 52.
And fly up it too.
Holy cow.
Reload is R.
Oh, so it is.
That would make sense, no?
There's the one that I need to get to.
if only this wall wasn't in the way.
I wish I had a flying pal.
But we could just jump with the chillet, right?
If you shoot empty, it will reload.
Ah, gotcha.
Go get one.
I could.
This is a great vantage point, isn't it?
Wow.
Wow-wee.
Is there anything else around here?
Um, let's...
I don't want to use my chillit, but...
My deer is dead.
I did yoyink that guy, but I don't think I have his saddle
yet.
Unless...
Homeward Thundercloud transports you to the nearest base.
Cannot be used in dungeons.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's a consumable, though.
Yuck.
Never mind.
I could go for the mega grappling.
level 25
is it because I didn't technically buy him that I can't see
it that I can't see it that sucks large feed bag oh the
metal helm I already have that though
boost gun where you see that yet flea market for facility
for selling pals Oh my god.
Wait, I could sell them to other players.
Okay, never mind.
Stunbaton.
Pal Expedition Station.
Facility that allows pals to be sent on expeditions to
places like Dungeons.
Wait, that's kind of huge, no?
Large toolbox development.
Where is that?
My goodness.
There's so many things that I haven't done.
I guess I'll get a cooler box because I Haven't unlocked it
yet Holy I'm sleepy It's literally huge Yeah, it sounds like
it, no Oh, the Malpaca
Monitoring stand Oh, yeah, this is the stuff that like I
mean, other people are building them But I should know how
to build them too Oh, here, here Oh, night Wing saddle Did I
get this guy and the r socks that's the guy i got that's the
guy from the but he'll overheat me right
mada gave him to him yeah yeah everybody will be impressed
with how much you improve the base plus you can rub it in
doki's face no no it's fine though there's so much like Like
there's so much structure and stuff for like building all I
want to do is explore I'm such an explorer.
I'm like build a base.
What you mean like furnace Furt for for for fun for What's
the word when you put furniture down
Furnish Don't burn I don't want to furnish it And Nimi was
doing such a good job anyway.
Human power generator!
No, we need it!
We need it!
Okay, I'm going to stop looking at stuff.
And we're going to...
Good job.
We're going to ride Chill It.
Ride him.
Put him on.
Get on top of him.
Ride him.
Ride him right now.
Uh.
Ride him?
Okay, I give him.
Oh.
I'm gonna talk to this guy again.
We'll let him out.
Oh, you again.
If you change your mind, I really appreciate a rescue.
I'll pay you handsomely.
Is he gonna actually?
Captured adventurer.
Submission.
I had to do a flip for it.
I had to trust.
You've released the mysterious figure from the cage.
Freedom!
can't thank you enough for getting me out of that pickle pal
tamer usually i wouldn't let folks like them get the better
of me but i got suckered in by all their sweet talk next
thing i knew they stripped me among all my gear and shoved
me in that dumb box whoops i guess i should have kept my
volume down here they come do
your thing buddy i'm also gonna shoot them and catch them
did you do anything oh oh come on Oh, good job.
What are you doing with your lightsaber there, buddy?
Hello?
Literally doing nothing.
He got stuck?
Oh, is he supposed to help?
He's a Jedi.
Well, thank you kindly.
Thank you.
Would you kindly let me out of the box?
The name's Harold.
I go where the wind takes me, so I guess that makes me some
kind of adventure.
That's me too.
That's enough about me.
It'd be a right shame to go without knowing the name of my
savior.
Minto!
Gotcha.
That's a good, solid name.
We're buddies in arms now.
And seriously, can't thank you enough for getting me out of
there.
Whoops, I almost forgot.
I was on my way back from finishing up.
Request some local folks gave me.
I better hurry if I can get my reward.
They have some peace of mind.
Much as I hate to chat and run, I really gotta get going.
Hey, maybe our paths will cross again sometime.
Wah!
On that note, here's hoping the gods stay good to you,
Minto.
Thank you.
See ya.
Alright, we're gonna go get the um
this.
I'm so curious what's up there though, no?
Everything I'm curious about.
There's nothing that I'm not curious about.
There's nothing that I don't want to see and explore and
look at.
All right, chill it.
Yeah.
Hoi!
Nice.
There's a base down below.
I saw it.
Pretty sure I've been to that one, though.
It was funny because I had explored that entire area around.
Minus.
Minus that one area.
That was just super dark on the map.
out thank you now for the gifted we're too heavy okay go
back one more time one more time oh uh i guess that works
too where is it oh it's up here okay we're too heavy
Nice.
Creamus.
Creamus?
It doesn't matter.
All I see is...
Get creamedish.
Did you see that?
Lamb ball?
Was that frightening to you?
Busket style.
Oh, this is the church that we saw from up since...
Maybe?
Oh, hi.
Got some good items in stock.
This is all the same stuff I saw before!
Pituy!
Pituy on you!
Wait, where's the...
Am I crazy?
Oh, it's down here.
Somewhere.
What a totally trustworthy fella.
There it is.
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
What
are you selling?
Whoa, gosh, oh my gosh, I was just going to be like, wow,
we've done so much, but there's, look at those, look at how
little of the map we've explored.
Scouring Islet, what the heck is that?
And how is it on my, wait, what is, what is the, oh, that's
where the items, wait, I tried getting those and I died.
I remember.
Wait, I kind of want to get this guy.
we got the other ones.
I didn't get this guy, though.
Guys, I have to go to the little ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
Come back.
Let's go kill somebody.
Let's go kill this guy.
Let's go kill this.
What is Mata doing?
I wonder.
Well, wait, fast travel can all be... Oh, wait, where am I?
Oh, fast travel.
Yeah, yeah.
Fast travel to you.
Yeah.
Yeah!
welcome back thank you so much we're gonna get this guy
thank you guys for the for the duper chance thank you
what do you want to know about the bounties there are people
who are wanted for very oh wait the cheater the cheat the
gloating narcissist that guy with the devil's tongue huh
he's a master at turning any conversation into one about
himself wait why is there a there's a bounty on a for being
too into himself.
Recently, he's even gone as far as tying people up just to
force them to...
Okay, never mind.
Maybe that's not good.
Remember, Hazel?
He shows up in the valley to the north of the lake shore.
Once you hear his story, you'll have your life sucked out of
you.
Like, actually?
Or...
Let's get these Hangures.
Sounds like a Doki.
Doki.
tying people up to listen to her stories.
Yeah, but her stories are so strange, no?
I think I got him, though.
Come on.
Yeah.
Is this...
Are we hunting, Matta?
Gosh, I sure wish.
I think I need one more, no?
What's this?
Oh, my inventory is full.
Since when?
I've been doing so much hunting and stuff let's get this guy
it's rabbit season wait not that guy was there anybody else
oh you're a little closer maybe maybe hang you hang you hang
you I eat hang you's for lunch stop doing that stop I was
gonna say stop running but doing whatever the heck you're
doing there okay hopefully hopefully
Okay.
Yeah!
He left me a rock.
Oh, no, there's wheat seeds.
Okay.
We are heading...
Oh, right over here.
It's right over here.
Wait.
I'm confused.
Was he supposed to be here before?
Oh, there were so many down here.
I'm just dummy dumb.
Wait.
Level 15 turncoat.
Has he already been killed?
Floats menacingly.
A?
B?
Oh?
Mr. Turncoat.
It says that I have...
You think Mata got him?
Oh, maybe.
That could very well be possible.
Anything is possible.
Let's go this way!
We're here, why not?
Oh wait, maybe...
Maybe I should go home.
Let's go home and fix my dear.
Oh dear, Aqua Bomb.
Welcome back, thank you.
Anything is possible.
He should respawn, right?
Eventually.
I believe that is the intention.
And manage my inventory.
Yes, yes, yes.
we have multiple reasons to be here all right get healthy
get healthy now we could take my deer, my other deer replace
one deer with another deer oh dear oh dear I don't, wait,
that's terrible, I'm not giving away all my arrows, wait, I
don't even want all of them though uh, take hand oh, no, no,
no, no They're not all mine.
That's the one bad thing about QuickStack, you know?
Wait, I'm also taking...
I'm taking some bait.
Wait, stop, stop, stop, stop!
I keep not doing left!
Okay, here we go.
The shift.
Low-grade medical supplies.
Honestly, I feel like I'm so bad.
No arrows for Doki.
That's fine.
That's fine to do.
Let's do...
Let's enhance my
My stamina, maybe Use the bulk transfer as a way Wait, how
do I bulk transfer again?
I can't remember If I am here Wait, no, it's in my inventory
And then I Press F or something or R Ah Ah, okay How do I
say no thank you guys oh wait
oh here we go oh i see how it works i see how it works oh
this i add this i add oh no that goes this my gold we can do
the assault rifle i don't have one this oh no leather
leather can go away okay yeah okay okay awesome
okay cool that's it
how's the pal taming going it's going great I think I think
I'm having fun let's go back what is this now this is the
gob fin we don't really want to deal with those guys oh I
should Pelfadron oh she's getting Pen King I think I should
unlock this huh Alright, let's go back.
Making good Paraguers?
I did shell the assault ammo, yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure I...
Whatever, it's fine.
Even if I didn't.
Alright, let's go.
We're right at dawn.
Whoa, wait, this is sick.
I remember getting attacked here and almost dying.
It was just like yesterday.
now oh i freed one of you guys okay so they're more in my
level range here now i'd say uh let's go this away and we'll
go get the every time i see this dang muffly i want to call
it miffy whoa wow there's so wait is this kind of not
awesome if we can hit so many of them at once Wait, no,
don't separate!
You were so perfectly stacked!
No!
The big ruins to the north are cool.
Well, we are kind of heading there right now.
Oh, these?
Well, howdy-duty.
Look at that.
Oh, hello.
There we go.
All right.
Check this out.
Oh, no, no, oh, I messed up.
Oh, I can't even see them.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, don't kill them.
Oh, we lost one.
Oh, shoot.
We're fine, we're fine.
This place, oh my gosh, really?
Really?
Uh-oh, don't watch.
Whatever you're seeing, it's not happening.
not real what strike thank you so much for the super chat
look how oh my gosh they look so cute what did i grab oh
some tomato seeds why what is happening here actually wait
wait are they wait what is going on here actually
oh what's happening
Like, they refuse to separate.
Okay, so maybe attacking all of them at once is kind of a
little overwhelming.
But, I think we did a pretty okay job.
Where were we?
Oh, yeah, I want to get this one over here.
Maybe we go around the trail.
Freaking couples, am I right, man?
Oh, my gosh.
Ancient Ritual side.
Wait, there's a cave here!
You think I can...
You think we can handle it by ourselves?
If not, we can call Mata.
29!
If we have Mata here, we might be able to do it.
Where am I headed?
Okay, the right way.
Doable together.
I think so.
Wait, how much is this guy?
30.
I'm 23.
But that still makes me nervous.
It's just like a tiny bit too much, I'd say.
Gale Cloud.
Oh, here we go.
Free Pal Alliance Believer.
Wait, so you want the pals to be free, but what is happening
here?
Wait, what's going on?
Be free?
Oh, wait, it won't let me do it.
Free from life!
Clearly.
Oh, wait.
Who did I get?
Oh, come on, buddy.
Oh, they got him.
My stinking horse.
Why are you gonna be...
Are they eating the dead body?
Wait, I thought I heard somebody.
He's gonna say that's nuts.
Wait, how do I free you?
Oh, here we go.
I'm releasing you, pal.
I'm releasing you.
Become my ally.
These are pretty cute, though.
Flambel.
When it starts crying, this pal produces magma in place of
tears.
And then it is absorbed back into the body, causing it to
get hotter and hotter.
the more the stronger it gets.
Now where is the quick?
Where is it?
Am I blind?
The VTuber is blind.
Wait.
I'm actually blind.
Oh, it's more this way.
Oh, it's up there!
We know.
You know nothing.
I think I need to climb.
From here.
Here we go.
Climbing up.
Gamers never look up.
It's so funny the way it's like...
Eh-oh, eh-oh, eh-oh, eh-oh.
Down the hill.
You've heard of somersaulting down the hill, but the real
meta is somersaulting up the hill.
It's really...
It's really great.
And efficient.
Really effective.
Fast!
Travel!
What's in here?
Join boss battle.
Oh, uh, wait, can I, oh, how do I know what the boss, wait,
uh, level 20, we can do this, we can do this, um, hold,
unless we want to, it's the second boss tower, it's level
20, that's not bad, I think we got it, I think we got this,
maybe, I hope so, I hope so.
Wait, this is the main quest!
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
I think we'll win Fox Sparks for this.
Ahu!
She's cute!
Lilian Lion.
Uh, wait.
There we go.
Come on.
Yeah, Fox Sparks!
You got this!
My gun is so freaking slow.
Okay, I think we're going to need to change out the gun for
my sword.
Fuck Sparks, you got this!
Oh my gosh, run!
Run, fuck Sparks!
Oh my god, fuck Sparks, run!
I'll distract her!
Wee, wee, wee, wee!
Oh.
You're right.
You guys are so right.
You guys are so smart.
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh shoot.
I'm in trouble.
Nope.
That's not what I wanted to do.
My armor is damaged.
Chill it!
Okay.
Time to switch to bow and arrow.
Chill it.
You got this?
Oh, he's not, he's not, he's not healed up enough.
Oh, shoot.
But I think I...
Oh, no, no, no!
Yeah, go, cat, go!
Oh, highly effective!
Wait, are you fire type?
Would you just heal?
I'm gonna kill you.
Don't melee bosses.
Don't tell me what to do.
I'm hungry?
No way.
Wait, I don't have any food, do I?
I do.
Come
on!
You have to do it!
Thank, this guy's tough.
Oh my gosh.
Catamount, you have to!
Okay, Fox Bark to go.
We just need to get them as low as possible.
This is gonna be really, really, really down to the wire,
you guys.
Oh my gosh, wait, we're so close.
And we did it.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
That was so freaking close.
Holy cow.
That was intense.
Oh, this is the first and only time I've ever seen Adazi do
something.
Oh my gosh, I hope I I hope that I was able to like Um This
is a power rank from zero to one I hope I was able to get
the stuff Oh
Let's go back home
Catava the MVP.
Let's go!
That's my pseudo Souls player, Ghostman.
The only HP that matters is the last one.
So true.
Sheesh.
Catava was awesome.
Oh, look at my party.
Okay, let's find how to get home from here.
That's okay.
we're going home wait no not at all actually not at all You
know when you said you wanted a horror game?
You know when you said you wanted a horror game?
Yep, yep.
Yeah, here it is.
Here it is.
Actually, it's your turn.
Can you help me make the sword?
Yeah, yeah.
Let me repair my armor.
Oh, yeah.
Do your stuff.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, am I doing it?
It sounded like I heard a ghost.
Wait, is it repairing it?
wait where'd it go oh i guess it repaired it oh okay it
repaired it just kidding i forgot to eat by the way because
i was having too much fun i know i have to go eat dinner
soon i'm getting hungry repairs one click what do you gonna
have skeddy with ketchup with ketchup ew no i don't like it
skeddy with ketchup is so good don't eat it We're doing it
on the better thing and it's still so slow.
Holy cow.
We're doing our darn best.
Oh my gosh, I just had an intense battle.
Tell me, tell me, tell me all about it.
I used, wait, hold on, I'll come back.
I have to put all my guys away so they can heal.
Yeah, no worries.
I need to summon somebody with handiwork.
I have a pal with me.
Oh, my guy who has it is dead.
No, no, no, I have a guy.
I have a guy.
Oh, okay, okay.
I actually don't know if it's going to be so slow.
It's pretty slow still.
Wow, the sword is like so OP.
I want it.
Do you have somebody working on it?
Oh, Dazzy can help.
Yeah, let's not summon that.
Wait, summon?
Work?
We're working?
Okay.
Work, work.
We're working.
Oh, it's only one at a time, though.
I don't know.
Yours might be.
better than mine i think this guy's faster because my little
guy he is 50 slower of working at the because he's like
stronger at fighting oh tell me about your battles i want to
know everything i did the second tower which i guess is like
the story one and it said it was like level 20 so i was like
oh easy but it's like oh my gosh it was like this lady and
her giant guard of war
crazy and all my all my pals died except to rip yeah we loki
killed a baddie when they when they sent out the attack you
can like put him back in your hey hey oh sorry hold on wait
a second wait oh they're waking up nice oh nice okay
no do you do best joan huh the youtube is show and sometimes
my youtube if you've typed much but um it's the opposite
people type very little because they're sleeping oh no when
you do you always have like a main and a side i've wondered
if i should stream on twitch but i don't know sometimes like
there's games the games that have like like i was playing
water park simulator yesterday and apparently it to your
chat so they'll be like in the park you should do it yeah
yeah yeah maybe i should do it water park simulator write
that down write that down write that down yeah i think
obviously i mean i think you've built a youtube audience
audience loves that about you but realistically i think if
you just did a game like that but you multi-streamed it yeah
i think they would forgive you for that right with what do
you think would you guys forgive me if i only played the
games on twitch that You can just even dual stream it if you
want.
Like, you don't even have to do it Twitch only.
So if they, if they're, for example, like, oh, screw Twitch.
I don't want to go there.
You don't have to.
Yeah, that's how I always feel.
Because I would always, I wouldn't switch from YouTube to
Twitch.
I would always dual stream.
Also, this is something I remember when Nietzsche and I
played this game.
People got to spawn in as the patients.
And then we got to beat them up.
Yeah, exactly.
That's fine.
Yeah, it was the best.
I wish YouTube would integrate stuff like that eventually.
I know, I know.
Actually, Ludwig talked about it.
It's because Twitch streaming is like their only thing that
they got.
So they're doing integration.
And for YouTube, they have so many others that Twitch, that
live streaming is just kind of at the bottom of their...
It is, it is.
But hey, mint on Twitch would be great if that's somebody on
my...
Just saying, you're going to have at least one fan if you
come to Twitch television.
Maybe if one person watches me.
Yeah.
Look at my big boy in the bag.
They're flashing back.
Where?
He's so cute.
You see him, the little green.
Oh, I see him.
A visitor.
Oh, what is he gonna sell?
He's good items in stock.
Oh, he'll buy stuff too.
You can sell to him.
Sell, sell, sell, sell, sell, sell, sell him some stuff.
Wait, I'm gonna buy some of the stuff that I needed
actually.
I buy stuff, my stuff.
Wait, I'm buying stuff.
I'm buying stuff.
Do we do?
She's buying?
She's buying.
really needed these oh wait this is awesome oh my god what
does he have what does he have tell me everything tell me
everything he has oil he's an oil cell salesman like snake
oil or crude oil snake and whatever your fans monkey snake
boar he's got it all he's got it all all the oils all the
every single oil sesame olive oh i do like a good sesame oil
me too oh my gosh
and capture him try it you might get wanted but i think you
can do that i think you can take that does it did it work
did you get like
i think as long as you don't attack him oh 31 oh oh my god
okay mint i'm just gonna put him in the thing so you can
take a look at him okay okay yeah
Oh my god.
Wait, he's actually such a little cutie patootie.
Wait, I want to see him.
Where is he?
Do you want to name him something?
Name him the the the oiler.
I don't know.
Wait, where do you go?
Where do you go?
He should be in our base.
He should be walking around the base.
Oh, is he?
Where is he?
Yeah.
Uh, grab him and then name him.
He's over here.
He's watering.
Wait, does he still sell us stuff?
Hey, merchant.
Oh my god, he dies.
He dies.
Wait, what?
and you can still sell to him holy huge wait that's huge
that's actually op good job girl what did i need for the
right okay what did i need the oil for i don't know i can't
remember there's something i need oil for oh my gun my gun
why do you need a gun for an oil huh i guess it i mean they
gotta be slick no Hey, come.
I'm working on your sword.
Get back here.
I'm coming.
Get back here, Matara.
Get back here.
The good gun.
Yeah, my good gun.
Hey, my gun is good.
It's just slow.
I can't say anything about your gun because you're going to
shoot me.
This is definitely faster.
Remember before we never stopped working on the...
Now it's like we stop, we take breaks, and we're still good.
Yeah, it's already halfway.
oh pal team is hungry how is my team so hungry all this
recently even though we have the feedback that's what i
don't understand either they're supposed to eat i know well
i mean i guess i don't have anything let me buy it let me
get some food i we have some cooked food oh your little fire
guy by the way is insane oh is he is he being a good worker
so every time i put in like i'm like oh 40 iron bars is
gonna take forever he instantly smashes them for me oh nice
wait let's see We can do all these.
We usually get those for me.
Yeah, we can do that.
Yeah.
He's such a good boy.
He's a good boy.
Okay.
Um, I don't need all this milk, so what we're gonna do with
this.
Oink.
Thanks for the raid!
Hello!
Hi-hi.
Welcome, Weiner.
Welcome.
There's like 44 milks, uh, 22 now in the chest if you want
them.
Eat them.
No, I have a ton of stuff.
Oh, okay.
all of them do it then come help me okay oh honey when did i
get that honey hi honey hi honey where did i put it did i
not put it in get your little ghost ass over to this
workbench please okay yeah we're almost on we're almost on
the worst part of Because after I do this sword, I'm not
going to want to log out.
Because I'm going to have the...
I know, right?
I'm going to have the freaking powers.
It's a good sword.
Just be careful with it.
It's very high responsibility.
With great power.
It's got a lot of aches.
I just thrust a little bit.
I'm worried about your arms.
They're a little skinny compared to mine.
True.
It's true.
I got to eat my protein.
You got a spinach.
Spinach.
I ate so much spinach.
And now I'm Popeye.
A.
Then, am I your olive oil?
No.
Well, you are pretty skinny.
I'm pretty tall.
Skella.
You're so skella.
Oh, I think you can barely see me.
Oh, my God.
Turn sideways.
You'll disappear.
Tell me about your battle.
You were fighting a baddie.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
She was awesome.
And she was like, you know, do you know that first girl we
fought, like, in the dungeons?
She was like, what is it?
She had like the Twin Tails or whatever.
Me and Nimmy fought her.
And then I think you fought her after.
Yeah.
She, it was like the second person.
It's like, I feel like they're like gym bosses almost if you
compare to Pokemon.
I like that.
Yeah, Zoe.
I thought Zoe, you guys.
Oh my god.
I'm going to go back to that scary island with a...
See if I can catch more.
Wait, were you going to catch what?
I want to see if I can catch more stuff on that scary drone
island.
Oh, yeah.
did you see the drone i did and i ran away from you oh but
it didn't spot me i wonder how fast it kills you if it spots
you i don't know yeah because apparently if it does shoot at
you it's like one hit one kill one shot one kill i've been
leveling up my health i got like a thousand health oh dang
okay wait i have unused stat points thanks for reminding me
use them use them you can use them for carry weight as well
yeah i know um what you're saying is gonna kill me in It's
gonna kill you in two hits.
I also increase my health.
My god, mid, we're almost done!
We're almost done!
75%.
Why is my kingpin always so sad and dying?
No, we can.
See if later we can see if we can get some meth.
Some meth?
Yes.
No, I met Medi-Key.
Oh, some methication.
Methication.
Oh, okay, okay.
Nah.
That would help him out probably.
I think so.
He's been depressed for a little bit now.
I feel bad.
What?
He's been depressed for a little bit now.
I feel bad.
She's been depressed for a really long time, yeah.
He's been depressed.
You think that human's gonna become depressed?
Oh my god, yes, definitely.
No.
I mean, we're working them to the bone, you know, and...
Yeah, absolutely.
But you know what?
Isn't it part of being human to be depressed?
Pretty NIMBY.
I like how you name all your things.
Yeah.
I always forget to name them.
Me too.
I realize I forgot to name them.
I've been giving off.
Wait, sorry, you keep cutting out.
I wonder, I think the voice.
Oh, I think this is, I'm moving away from my microphone.
Yeah.
I'm tired.
So I'm like, you know.
I told them, I told them it wasn't going to be a long
stream.
And now that you're about to finish this, Yeah, it's going
to be here for a long time.
Yeah, I'm getting sleepy.
I'm hungry.
I'm getting hungry.
Do you have them headpacks?
It'll cheer them up.
Cute.
They're just like me.
Yeah, headpacks and my sanity is like...
Ooh, idea.
We killed the depressed pal.
Oh, I worked hard to get him.
Actually, that's fine.
We have another one now.
No, no, we won't kill him.
Oh, you thought of two?
Yeah, no.
just replace it replace the sad one with the happy new shiny
one exactly and then the sad one will feel less sad if we
trap him in a small bop oh i was thinking you we could eat
him oh my god we should i'm gonna cut him up do you want to
cut him up because no you do the honors you do the okay i'm
gonna cut him up see i like when we're same same wavelength
yeah same wavelength same brainwave it's okay we can always
get another one guys yeah they spawn every hour yeah i
didn't know that i would have definitely been attacking them
a little bit oh he looks so sad oh he looks so sad he's
gonna it's okay he's gonna go to canada with with his mom
and parent oh canada that's where all the pals go when they
get sad they go to bro certainly don't kill them They grow
there.
And depressed.
They grow.
Wow, wow, wow.
Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
Well done.
Oh my gosh, it's almost done.
It's almost done.
Your sword!
Yeah.
For a second, I didn't see you there because I'm like
standing behind you.
So I was gonna be like, what are you doing?
I'm almost done.
You're not even helping.
And then I realize you're helping.
Can you give us back?
I got two of them now.
Can you give us back, please?
Please.
Please, man, give it back.
Beg for it.
Please, please, man.
Get on your knees.
Please, man.
Please.
All right, you know what?
mint if you don't do it you're paying no he's already so oh
whoa whoa i thought that guy was charging heavy you know
what mint oh no i actually i just wasted my gigabit wait
what'd you i'm having i wasted my gigaball oh here you go
you can have it it's too late mint i dropped it on the
ground it's too late mint oh my god oh my god oh Oh my god.
We got, wait, Min.
We got ancient civilization part.
From him?
Oh yeah, because he's a boss.
He's a boss.
Oh my god.
That is cool.
We're gonna kill more of these bombs.
Okay.
You forgot the R.
It's cruel.
What?
No, it's cool.
It's cool.
No, no, it's cool.
It's hip.
It's cool.
I'm hip.
I'm done.
Daddy.
Isn't she cute?
I'm gonna go check out one last thing and then I'll head
out.
So, um, I'll see you.
Can you give me the sword though?
I did!
I dropped it!
Oh.
Where'd you drop it?
Actually, it's gone though.
Did you pick it up?
No, I didn't.
Wait.
No, for real.
No, I don't believe you.
Wait, no, for real.
Wait, did you actually not?
Actually, okay, it's in one of these.
I was going to say, it's like...
After we spent half a year.
Oh, the pals will put them away.
Okay, okay.
Actually, yeah, they will.
They will.
Bye, mean.
Have fun.
If I don't see you on your way back, then goodbye.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
I want to go check out two more things, guys.
First, I want to check out that meteor, because I feel like
we picked it up, but it doesn't show that we picked it up.
And then I also want to go check out uh this because i feel
like we could probably handle it um it's north oh gosh you
scared me are you the one that went to the muffly yeah screw
you i don't want to talk to you i thought i captured a
muffly actually it's not wait maybe it's a new meager maybe
oh these guys are whoa wow what is always.
Oh, it is a new meteor.
Wait, that is a new meteor.
I forgot to grab my pals.
Okay, we're on limited pals, guys.
What is that?
Wait, they're like, oh my gosh, they're eating him.
It's definitely this, but I don't know what this is.
Special meteor pals.
Wait, that's what they are.
Wait, that's sick.
Um, okay.
Okay, let me get my gun out.
Or my sword.
This might be kind of scary.
I'm gonna get him.
No, no, no!
Come on, come on, come on.
Don't play hard to get.
Come on, don't play hard to get.
Oh, shoot.
My guy is dead.
Oh, my God.
And I'm almost dead.
No, I'm down!
No!
Mortala!
Please!
No!
If only this stinker didn't you, why couldn't you just...
You think she's gonna come get me?
My world is starting to...
My chilla is eating hot milk.
My world is starting to go fade to...
I'm losing color.
Out of my face, out of my body.
No, no.
Not like this.
It won't let me open the map, you guys.
It won't let me open the map.
Please, please, please, please, I'm going to die.
If you don't help me, then I won't get to revive.
Heartbreak is one thing, losing my pals another.
I can't believe she ignored me.
Respond?
Oh.
Respond back home?
Wait, did she, like, leave?
Oh, no, there she is.
She's on her way.
away not for honor but for you what's that get let's get my
pals from the box at least the ones that uh can help me out
okay i guess she's never been here before
subscriber only mode It should be on that.
Yeah.
To think it would end this way.
It's so painful.
Oh, hello.
It's fine.
We died not so far away.
Do you lose the pals you had on you?
Yes, but you'll grab them right here.
It's A-okay.
Don't tell me the aliens are gone.
Oh.
Wait, uh, open?
What do you call?
Oh, my bad.
Wait, are the aliens gone?
No, I even lost them!
No!
I'm stuck with these freaks!
Why are you so obsessed with- Why are you like this every
time around- Oh my god!
Mother Nature is happening!
She was laughing it up for- You know she was laughing it up
for 30 seconds.
Yeah.
Never...
Never mind.
Never mind, Tiki.
Man!
Can I mine this?
Oh, I can!
Whoa!
I can mine the meteorite.
When they love each other very much.
You can mine the meteorite.
I mined it.
Whoa, cool.
Okay, I guess that was worth it.
Ish.
Well, we checked it out.
There's another one.
Maybe this is the one.
I don't know.
Let's go fight this thing.
Oh, oops.
I forgot.
We'll go check this out and then I'll call it for the day.
Round two.
Why are my arms so big?
I'm just...
I'm a naturally bulky girl.
What can I say?
I mean...
I've worked hard for these games.
I just bulked up, baby.
Alright.
Eat your spinach.
That's all I gotta say.
Oh, yes.
We gotta do this village next time, too, for sure.
all right let's go north
the village chief is here everybody's here gossiping
villager what do you got to say gossip to me ever explored a
cave I've heard that caves are home to loads of unique pals
what's more there are even treasure troves created by pals
with a knack for collecting stuff give me a shout if you
spot any caves I don't want to I don't want to scare you but
have you turned around wait can we can we do this one let's
see oh my gosh oh this is easy yeah we could do this easy
she's she's glued to the chair she's she's never looked
she's never explored ever Wow oh my gun Wow, wait, is there
stuff in here?
There is.
I'm looting.
Nice.
I'm sure the loot in here is not going to be spectacular
because it is such a low-level cave, but that's fine.
I don't have a ton of...
What's the word, either?
Space?
Oh, this is where I can get a meow meow!
Whoa.
Oh.
Whoa!
Meow, meow.
Don't fall.
Hello, kitten.
Actually.
No, no.
I need more of you.
Oh, no.
Don't leave.
Oh!
Oops.
I tried- I tried anything.
And my finger slipped.
Stop running.
Ha!
Oh!
And I wasted it.
How embarrassing.
The worst.
What the?
Cheeky...
Cheeky bastard!
The game just...
The game just called you that!
The game just called you a cheeky bastard.
What the heck?
That's crazy.
Oh, here's the Kilimari.
There's a...
always two epic boxes at the end.
Almost guaranteed a stat potion and ancient tip.
Nice.
These guys are pretty cute.
No way it's a shiny in here!
Cool!
Whoa!
Okay, I have to be careful now.
Dang it.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, come on.
Don't be like that.
Don't be like that!
Did they do any damage to me?
Yeah!
We got him!
Oh, wait.
Like barely anything.
I'm gonna waste all my spears.
Actually, I don't really need these guys, huh?
But that's okay.
I see it's yellow, but it's okay.
inventory is full now yeah you're right we'll figure out
something yeah there we go oh we got the tentacles just
realized my bow is so low oh the training manuals let's use
this on like box sparks and I have so many keys I gotta put
away my hand good schematics I'm like them.
I'm like, oh, nobody else can use it.
Precious pal.
Oh, don't those sell for a good amount?
We can sell them to our guy.
Food bag is empty.
Thank you.
Everybody's hungry.
Oops.
My bad.
Oh, here we go.
Nice.
There we go.
Hope that contains long lost secrets of Technology.
Oh, ancient technology!
Yeah!
What's this one do?
Raises work speed.
Permanently.
Gulp?
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
And I leveled up!
Eee!
We'll do my stamina this time.
Yeah, permaspeed up.
Great.
Huge.
I'm going to grab these mushrooms.
And that...
Oh.
We might go back and drop off some stuff.
And then I'll go kill the thing.
Wait.
High quality bait.
Huge.
Cavern mushrooms are always in demand.
Are they now?
Okay.
Good to know.
Yeah, cave was worth the detour.
Oh, yes.
Hee hee!
Shiny, shiny fish.
All three of them are shiny.
This is crazy.
It's okay though.
Oh, oh.
Fishing is unfortunately not my forte.
um i mean we are pretty close but we won't be able to
collect anything so use the good bait yeah but my my i don't
think it's the bait's fault i think it's my rod my rod is
not good right i have to get a better rod i imagine is what
would be more dependent on whether you get it or not
Yeah, my rod is stinky.
Oh, wait, wait, hold on.
Uh.
R.
That's what it was.
Um.
Yeah, that's good.
Still.
Okay.
I still...
Okay, let's use up some of these things, right?
Um...
Uh...
Who?
Who did we put away in here?
Oh, you!
Which one's better, attack?
244 264 unstable passive skill okay maybe we keep this guy
around instead he's kind of um i don't want i don't need
anybody unstable all right let's um let's see can think of
lumbering affinity okay here we go i'm level 25 so let's use
it on you nice and fox to start using them, you know?
Uh, let's repair my bow real quick.
What's my passive skill?
Um.
Uh.
Doing this.
It's really rare.
You won't find it.
You won't find it often.
Wait, I'm gonna sell this.
Where's our pal?
Hey, buddy, wake up.
Wake up!
He's talking in his sleep.
Did she name him Limu?
Can I sell this?
Oh, select these.
There we go.
Thanks.
Pleasure doing business with you.
okay um i want to keep my dog coins i still i don't quite
understand wait
whatever whatever it's fine um successful bounty token oh
wait i didn't see this uh very cool very cool i'll throw
this in there i'll throw this in there i'll throw this in
there uh i think we had a schematics
not good at organizing things so um i'll let everybody else
handle that part okay let's go let's go back oh wait matta's
at the same place i am hi hello pokey how are you shawie i
get spooked what's up oh he said you died is that tool yeah
you ignored my chats i was asking for your help yeah i was
saying martha please help me i'm so so i was so locked in i
swear to you i'm so sorry like if you look at my stream i
swear to god i did i like people were coming into my chat
and i was like oh if she needs help she'll just tell me like
don't worry about it you know i thought he was he kind of
backseedy i'm so sorry how could you i lost the special
alien pals because of it no what do you mean the special
alien now yeah there's special alien pals they came from a
meteor trying to get them no oh that's what the meteors are
on the map some of them are some of them are okay i'm so
sorry that's okay i'm gonna go get this thing i'm coming
with you okay girl i just unlocked the flying for the level
25 mount oh wait the flying for the level 25 bird oh wait
what's the level 25 bird it's the one i bought up the guy oh
the one that's in my inventory right now oh yeah you took
him that's right i can make you the saddle no i i'm level 25
too oh damn don't get you yeah ignored blog i swear you know
how sometimes people are like oh my god go look at what's
happening there and i was like guys don't worry like if she
needs help she'll talk to me meanwhile you're crying and
begging i know i was on the ground being do you see the chat
in the game i do now i feel so bad i feel so bad i'm a bad
girlfriend you are i was dead wait am i going the right way
no i'm following nope we definitely aren't oh he's here he's
here he's here is it that big giant thing over there no he's
the big sexy giant thing i'm gonna summon a water because he
seems to be i was just gonna shoot him a fire yeah oh he's
20 level 23 okay king oh we got him we got him we might want
to um kill out the other two for well they're only level
five and seven okay now they're gonna get killed it's a
killer be killed world you know oh the smaller bug has
raided me i think she wants to get eaten mint do you think i
should keep the smaller bug yes always ah smaller bug my I
will eat the smaller bug.
Sorry, small bug.
Oh, wait, where'd he go?
Oh, yeah, he did.
Or something.
I'm taking my pal back.
Try catching him.
Yeah, so I'm doing.
Yeah.
Also, hi, Berry.
Hi, Berry.
Whoa!
We got him!
let's go he's very chunky and very cute yeah he's very cute
i want to put him in the base abilities he has cool go oh
wait check out his abilities um yeah oh wait we have to go
home don't weans for that or no oh maybe we do maybe we do
or can i check the palpedia you could but i just go to the
base okay let's go home yeah there's a pal thingy here yeah
I follow Yeah, here's the closer one I'll follow you Thanks,
Barry for the race Oh my god, Mint Did I tell you the Korean
incident?
Yeah, I think so Yeah, I mean, I said this on stream So they
know But, um Hi, B-O-E Hi, B-O-E Hope you're having a good
day Oh, shoot And if you're having a bad day Don't Oh, oh,
oh, stop, stop Okay, wait, Mint I need to grab these guys.
I need to capture them because I need, like, a million of
their life force, okay?
Oh, I got a couple of them, you know, earlier.
Gold hog.
Nice hog.
The Korean incident?
Do you want to explain for those who have not heard?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, by the way, I was completely sober.
So my count of accidental racism happened while I was in
drink.
Basically, I was wearing high heels and it was very loud.
I met who I thought was Barry while I was in heels and it
was loud.
And for some reason, the person that I thought it was, was
Pia.
And thank you for your honesty.
Honestly, it takes a lot being this brave.
So I kind of, for some reason, when Pia first spoke, the
rasp in her voice made her sound like Barry.
I know that sounds crazy because you're going to say all
small women don't sound the same.
But these two small women sort of did that night while I was
not drinking, like genuinely.
genuinely and it was loud genuinely um but yeah and so as i
said hello to pia whom i thought was very i all i said was i
thought you were korean what the heck that that's like
basically the first thing i told oh there she goes there she
goes and uh here we are here we are yeah it's okay i also
did one more accidentally raised thing that weekend i also i
told them about the uh wait i didn't when i talked about the
boys and the girls kissing and you're like matara girls and
girls boys and boys kiss stop living in the past i told them
about that what else have i done i did a lot of stuff she
does everything you guys and all of it's sober too that's
crazy oh yeah let's go look at my guy now yeah yeah show me
your guy show me your little guy is a heavyweight and a all
wait is he me and he can be ridden i think he is you all
right all right all right all right look at that he's king
of muscles you can have him if you want also i think i'm
good for my current ones but thank you you can you can you
can sell to the merchant while he's asleep wait what What
does that mean?
I'm just saying.
He talks in his sleep.
Oh.
And also gives good heels.
Good heels?
Deals.
Oh, oh, oh.
But also maybe he gives good heels as well and we never
know.
We never know.
Okie dokie.
Well, I'm going to say bye.
Yes.
Bye bye.
Okay, guys.
This was fun.
Oh, pal world, the grip you have on me.
Actually, I thought I would end like an hour ago.
Oh, come back.
Come back, horse.
We will explore more next time.
Honestly, I just want to, I might like, well, I don't know.
I kind of want to say like a grind off stream, but just so I
can get my level a bit higher and stuff.
Um...
but this is so fun this is so fun i'm starving though i am
what is that guy doing down there i think he's lost oh my
god he's cold he's shivering he doesn't know how to swim oh
he's gonna die don't worry about it i had so much fun i hope
you guys did too i will see you when i see you next don't
forget the egg incubator i checked it it was at like six
hours or something the second egg too i'm i give up i give
up thanks for the stream my vacation is over so back to work
for me tomorrow i hope everyone has a good week or at least
tries to have a good so go back to work virulent thanks for
the stream that boss fight earlier was super impressive your
brain must be mush after form at forming words from so much
going on a busket so way to lock in good night ps your super
cute passive skills reduces a stun effect that makes you op
thank you everybody Thank you, thank you!
Outsumi!
Bye bye!
We will pal!
Again!
Later!
Yo!
You've barely scratched the surface, the map is legitimately
huge.
It feels like it...
Bye!